Boom, Corey Anderson, ladies
and gentlemen, what's up?
How are you man going on?
Joe Joey's,
they finally did it,
finally did it and got
some techno Huntin as well.
I told you about that game. That game is
very addictive, isn't it? I worry, right?
Trying to get back out there, do some more
when it's over. So itchy, right? Yeah.
Yeah. No, it's amazing man
that, that game. Incredible.
How long have you been bow hunting for?
I've been bow hunting since I was 16
or 17 I've been hunting my whole life.
Wow. What switched you over
to bow hunting? I'm a high
school teammate, actually.
I used to go rabbit hunting stuff with
a shotgun and I've been shooting a bow
since I was like 12 or 11 just 3d
shooting a year. Bowhunter weirdly,
you can hunt with this. He's like,
yeah, like we go hunt all the time.
So one day before school he picked me up
and like went over to my buddy's house
and got up in the stand.
When he got in the stand I couldn't
climb cause he know what I was doing.
I got stuck at the bottom of the tree,
you know, I'm a bowl on my lap so,
but that was my first time and after
that I just kept going every now and then
in between practices and whatnot.
But now when I got time between fighting
or whatnot, I'm all hunting. That's it.
Oh, I could tell by your Instagram.
I follow your Instagram, all your,
you're constantly shooting and hunting,
practicing and it gets in your blood.
Let me just like fighting. Like I said,
we're doing,
taking the hunters,
I do it so much just muscle
memory and like everybody thinks,
oh you spend too much time hunting, you're
not training. When I go win a fight,
they're like, oh that was impressive. Like
I still train two or three times a day,
but I get home from the gym and
I always have a bowl on my truck.
I have three bowls on one is
always on my truck. So I pulled up,
popped the doors open, grab my
speaker and the target is right there.
Get like 30 to 60 shots and then go in
and spend time with the family, eat,
go back to the gym,
go to the range and shoot indoors and
it's dark and I'm always shooting.
I just enjoy it. Wow. So is it like a
part of meditation for you, do you think?
100% coming off the OSP fight.
That was actually the first
time I find it in Jersey.
I've been in Jersey since 2014 when the
show came out and I have to Osp fight
and all that stuff and everybody told
him like don't pay it to you was winning
that fight you got caught.
Don't let the people getting your
head and tell you you're not there.
So actually the next day I went home and
went and bought my hunting license and
bought a Standing Hunting Jersey for
the first time and that helped me.
I didn't think about it all from November
to February 1st I was in the tree
saying every day,
and I went back to training,
like full camp with everything and my
mind, I forgot all about that OSP fight.
And that's when I told my wife,
I found my balance. You know,
the thing was I was always in the gym
and that's why the name 25 eight came
because Corey never at the time I didn't
do anything else with train. You know,
we're trained to go to the
gym and train to go therapy,
go back to the gym and train, go home,
ruin, go to the garage at the heavy bat,
go to Mark Harris hip
pads and go train again.
So like I was telling the wheel on the
way here, my first one in UFC and I say,
oh, Cory's grew. He's gotten bigger,
they haul. It's been a big guy.
I was 300 pounds one time, but when I
got down to two oh five I was so myself.
I don't want to get heavier than like
two 10 to 12 so every day I had like a
goal. I wanted to end the day off, no.
Hebard and to 12 so I was like two 15
from eating too much and it's 10 o'clock
at night. I got to lace up and
go for a run. So I was all,
every morning I'll wake up at two 10 so
that's why I took the fight like young
black boy was on two three weeks notice,
five Maldonado in Brazil on a week notice
because I didn't have to cut weight.
It was like, okay, just go.
But when I got to Jimmy Manual and he
told me at the bar, he's like, Bro,
you're a good fighter.
He just too small.
Like I weighed in Friday and Saturday I
slept in the cage looking at exact same.
I gained like six pounds and he told me,
you gotta eat, you gotta feed yourself.
And after I did that,
that was probably the best advice I ever
got from a fighter because now I walk
around like two 35 and I
feel great like the last,
well fight with Glover on two weeks.
Notice I was two 36 I got the weight
off and hydrated right back up and felt
fine. Fantastic. And we're not there
and did my thing because I teach,
treat my body right now.
So your two 36 up until like how far out
of the fights and I'll try to stay at
least 230230230 one until like two weeks
out and I started tapering down to 25
area and just get 20 pounds
of water off a lot of water,
drinking the Waterloo and
then Tuesday is the first.
I hit it hard and just
start trimming down.
So you feel like the extra
pounds helps you in what way?
At recovery as we are
getting rocked as well.
Like that was the thing in college my
coach was always trained and rest and
we're going to go a whole practice.
Nobody go get a water.
If I see anybody go to the waterfowl,
we doing sprints,
whatever that mean you weak,
you know.
And it was great cause we train and in
the map you see guys gasping for water in
third period we all
standing tall ready to go.
And I had that same mentality when it
came to fighting cause you gotta think now
he's taking blows to the head.
So I got to keep water,
keep that brain hydrated because if I'm
dehydrated that one shot is lights out.
You don't have anything to help
take it. So it's like, like I said,
after LSP fight and the
hunting and everything,
I just went back and did a lot of figuring
things out before that Pat Cummings
fight. And I just knew what I had to do
to be the best me. And uh, like I said,
getting bigger, stronger, not
wearing about keeping my weight low,
the weight going to come off.
It's going to be hard sometimes,
but it's gonna come off, you know?
But that's when I will not miss.
What if I got to kill myself. I'm ended
up in the hospital before I miss. Wait.
So putting all that together and
I feel like I have the recipe.
So the recipe was, um, did
you start weightlifting?
Like what did you do to pack on the extra
weight? Weight lifting was a big thing.
Big Key to my brother first before I had
the strength and conditioning coaches
that was on board. My coach before
it was great for cargo, same guy,
frank Yeager hat and we had conduct
cardio and we were getting strong but it
wasn't like size building shrunk.
It was like mobility strength
to punch and keep the cardio up.
And then my brother,
he had a contract to play pro ball
back in like 2000 or whatever.
So he knew like all the combine list and
whatever. He hit me up and said, Bro,
we got to get bigger. Like we
got you, you, your dominant.
Like you look at these guys who fight,
they say you're going to lose.
You go out there and you
dominant in your small.
So imagine if you put the size on
it, you've got the power, you will,
you can dominate these guys for real.
So he flew out like I fly off a week,
you put me on the right diet and how
y'all lifted in the NFL camps or whatnot
and we get stronger. So she literally had
me on compound lifts every day eating.
Like I said, I got the freezer
full of deer. Me, he's like,
you got all the stuff you need.
You got protein right here.
Have the Jenny go grab my wife, go grab
rice and potatoes and you just eat meat,
potatoes, rice, eat eggs
for meat, potatoes and rice.
Everything you eat, put meat,
potatoes and rice and everything
and you're going to get that aside.
I promise you in the strength and
everything would come and sure enough,
I just saw it. I want it from like
after. This was after the Jimmy fight,
he showed up and it worked out as well.
I met my supplement sponsor,
but we went out to the buffet. Like I had
a good workout. We don't eat the buffet,
eat as much with carb up. And actually
while I was there, a pile of nutrition,
the owner of myself going to come
and he's like [inaudible], right?
Like I'm a huge fan.
I would love to work with you,
my brother that's made it happen.
Protein right there.
Get a bottle of protein from him.
We're going to start mixing
this sandwich once your meat,
potatoes or rice protein shake instantly
and he's put me on a whole plan and
when he left he left me a whole little
list on the frigerator and I still got it
there and I don't need it any more.
But that's the thing. Each and meat,
potatoes and rice. Four or five days
in the morning, it's got a cup of rice.
Put some venison or hard,
whatever meat I'm eating that day and it
put some vegetables and a little bit of
potatoes or so I can get a big old meal,
carve it up and then go hit the gym.
Then when you're done, kill your protein
shake, come on, meat, potatoes, rice.
How much difference is your diet
doing this than it was before? I mean,
it's crazy.
You ask my teammates now and they say
we seen a difference or how big you got.
Even Mark Henry,
I'll say miss the other day for the
first time with him and probably like a
couple of weeks, whatever in his basement.
And I was still moving. Fascinating.
I'm like Bro, you got huge like I
lifted the e coach. Yeah. You know,
so I used to work miss holding
yourself back before. Yeah,
100% and then probably
draining yourself too much.
But you all that weight cutting
and all that, uh, you know,
getting it down before
the actual fight itself.
All the extra running and everything.
Like even on the show,
like we were finished eating and that's
when I find out you can cut weight in
the hot tub. I didn't notice cough fall
headway before the ultimate fighter.
The Guy said, well, you can lose
weight and high tail. I was like, what?
And everybody was sitting the hots
off like 40 50 minutes and I get out,
I lost all my weight. I'm at
two oh six. Oh this is great.
So we eat a bunch like even one day.
Frankie and the coaches brought
in and out burgers over, you know,
we ate and watched the fights and I just
sat in his hot tub for like 40 minutes
and got all the weight off down the two
teeth they got and where I wanted to be.
I was like, Bro, you can get up.
So I'm like Nah, cause we fight.
We never know when we're going to fight.
He wins tomorrow on Tuesday.
I might be fighting Thursday.
I don't want to have to worry about that.
I was always scared of the weight cut.
If you getting in the sauna and or
getting a hot tub, losing all the weight,
that's just water weight though.
Right?
Even if you're down like
where you want to be,
you're still going to have
to cut more water. Yeah.
To get to where you need to be to do a
five. Yeah. But you could ask my wife,
I have the worst,
not now,
but before I didn't know anything about
nutrition because I wrestled heavy
weight from freshman year in high school,
my senior year in college and I fought
heavyweight until the ultimate fighter.
So I never had to worry about the Diet.
You know? I used to eat ramen noodles.
I remember moving in my first time
fighting Ben Asher and took me up to Rufus
Sport and I moved in the firehouse and
everybody eating like chicken filets and
salmon. I came in with a big old box
around it and thinking chunky new suit.
I was like, what are you doing?
Like this? Is this how he like, Bro,
that's not going to work.
What do you mean?
Like I train everyday
and I eat the same stuff.
Eat a bowl of cereal for breakfast
and they all cooking like Yo, that's,
that's not healthy.
Like it works for me.
But then when it came time to go to
two oh five the first time it's like,
oh this, this is a working from
me. I have to figure something out.
What do you feel the difference
between like eating nonsense,
like ramen and then eating healthy food?
Like what was the big shift?
You just have more energy really?
Because in wrestling that's how we ate.
You know? Definitely in
college you ain't got no money.
We go to Walmart long Saturday,
Sunday, get a big old box of rhyming.
I used to get spaghetti sauce and it's
cooked nude and put spaghetti sauce on it,
you know, uh, Canada's soup brought out
the can you eating, stuff like that.
But you train all day so it doesn't
really get to stick in your body and you
don't really feel the difference in
energy because you never really ate clean
eating.
Cafeteria food is packed with grease.
But now it's like we got
meal prep companies and stuff
out and you try all that
different stuff.
And then my wife fights too,
so she fought like one 20
so she was always dieting.
So when she's cutting weight,
I eat clean and I would notice
a difference in my energy.
Like I wake up a lot earlier,
I can go longer that day and
the night I'm not crashing.
I'm like peacefully put myself in bed,
watch TV and fall asleep when we got all
that sugar and all this stuff and you
feel like crap my end of the day you
kind of like, you just fighting you,
you don't have control anymore. We also
have the advantage of the best protein.
The fact that you have, how many did
you say shot 13. A lot of protein,
lots of protein,
clean,
wild protein and I got half
that meets still in Texas.
That never got actually just engage.
You got it.
And I heard they went hunting together
one time he gave me his coach,
Lou colonial, whatever.
And we put the meal,
I say his last name but they put the meat
in the same place and we said some of
this goes to Corey and the other part
go to Justin where they sent all of it
down to Justin and his camp. But
aside, I had a freezer full anyway.
I had no space. Yeah, he's another one.
Ray Borg. He's another he bow hunts.
Chad Mendez, bow hunts, Tj
Dillashaw bow hunts. Uh, when we,
we could probably keep
going down the line.
There's a lot of profilers who bow hunt.
Well let's put it out there before we get
too far. Justin. But he can't bow hunt.
He can,
we had with a crossbow on her ranch and
we pushed like everybody had got him and
he kept missing.
We put him in a corner guy,
we're gonna all like drive him
to be ready Bro. Just shoot
some out.
All these big old deer come,
but he's still miss like they was probably
10 yards to the 50 or he mills like
crossbow, the crossbow, like, Bro, how the
hell did you miss? Like you can't shoot.
Then they went to another ranch
and the guy gave him a gun.
Like he won't do a gun instead he
killed him with a gun. But he has a,
his vision is not the best right now.
What is wrong with his vision and
his energy? You know, he's kind of,
I mean he's a great guy. He's his
energy, bad energy. Kind of like focus.
That's what I mean.
Like it's hard him to like sit still
like we in the trees or in this loft and
he's like shadow boxer. So
like Bro, you gotta chill,
calm down when you're hunting.
Some people can't hang out in the stands,
they can't stand.
It's hard for them.
It's harder for them than
just a spot in stock.
Just walking in the mountains for all day.
It's easier for them than to just
stay put and do nothing. Yeah,
it's just sitting there quiet.
Um, I went with a buddy,
we went and Turkey and this is my first
week Turkey hunting this year and he's
never heard it before.
He's actually my Archie pardon?
I taught him how to shoot bow like 15
weeks ago and he's actually got pretty
good. He was hitting like all bulls
eyes and league and he's like,
I want to go hunting with you.
So he sat in the blind,
not telling me was going out there like,
Bro, we get out here, you got to do,
you can't move like we in the blind,
but that one window to turkeys can see
us if you move and they're going to see
you and they got good hearing excuses.
You got to chill out. So I'm like,
I'm going to put the decoys up.
Just sit down. I turned around,
he's like walk around like, what are
you doing? I'm covering the blind.
If you got like a little bitty Twiggs he
like, Bro, we don't have time to blind.
He's like, I seen it on youtube. It's
like getting the blind. I was like,
pro getting the block,
does it work? Does it work?
We're not going not kill anything. And you
know, talking to like call, call, call,
call was like, do it, can't do it. I was,
they get bored. It was like, exactly.
He just attention span. Some
people don't, they can't sit there.
I could sit there for a whole day from
sunup to sundown. I'm fine with that.
I'm fine pieces,
listen to the birds and watch the animals.
I have my phone checking my phone every
once in a while. But some people they,
they don't have that piece.
They need to be talking to doing things.
That's real add, right? Yeah. Yeah. It's
uh, it's, it's a weird mental exercise.
Just sit there and do nothing and just
wait for an animal to come to you.
And it seems like it would be easy,
but after a while it starts fucking with
your head. You know, it's, it's, um,
it's a mental exercise. The thing that's
crazy. I can do that in a tree stand.
But in college I couldn't focus a shit
and that's cool. Yeah. If I'm, even now,
if I go to like a meeting or something
and people are talking and I was like,
those, no, it's the, I can't sit
there, but that treats, I could sit.
Why wait for hours though?
You're waiting for something
that's very specific.
If you're doing something
you don't want to do.
A guy like you who burns off
so much energy in the day,
your body is probably like, this is
boring as fuck. Let's just not out. Yeah.
Well let's just train in six hours a day.
It's the same way at home.
I mean, my wife said you, you never
stop moving. Just hang out. You know,
Willis and I'd be baby to have my baby
and I'm doing something with the camera,
editing my youtube channel, so I can't
just sit down until I fall asleep.
How to do something. But like when it's
time just relaxed, like it's Sunday,
we're just gonna sit here and watch TV,
sit down five minutes and I'm out.
What'd you think wouldn't move like,
Huh? My bad babe. I fell asleep.
Yeah. Well, if you're a guy
who trains as much as you,
I mean every chance your
body gets to actually rest,
your body's probably like right about now.
It's a good time. It doesn't take much.
We're getting the car.
Probiotics are hours driving am
Oh, have to drive. Well yeah, my bad bay.
Well a guy who works as hard as you do
because one of the things that you are
known for man is your cardio.
You have crazy fucking cardio and you
notice it and fights where around the
second and the third round I start seeing
your opponents start to slow down a
little bit and then you ramp it.
[inaudible] face.
A perfect example.
That was a great five for you
because that guy's a tank is a tank.
Very scary dude. Hits really
fucking hard, strong as shit.
But he's a, he's a guy that
relies on that explosive power.
He's like a sprinter and a lot of ways
and you can only do that for so long and
you could say like somewhere around the
second round it was real obvious that
you weren't slowing down at all and he
was taking some big deep breaths and it's
just, it's harder for him. Have
you always had that kind of cardio?
I mean, I got it in the restaurant. I
guess I was big, you know, and I was,
especially when I got to 300 pounds
and I was still working cardio,
trying to get down as a
heavyweight to wrestle and B,
I always studied little guys film,
you know,
like the Hendrix udo film to shit
like that when I was in college.
That's just what I'll wash. My clothes
are like wash heavyweights. Nobody. Nah,
I wanna move. I won't footwork. I
want to fake, I want to take shots.
Like I lead my team and take downs as
a heavyweight because I moved around.
He's a big guy and the same
thing I've had matched one match.
The guy was beating me.
What?
15 one if you need one more point
to text me going to the third point,
but he in third round but he
gas and I was still going.
I came back and beat them in overtime
because I can just keep going.
I was the mindset guys is
going to break eventually.
My coach always says act fresh.
Even if you're tired, his dog,
she stand up and act
fresh like no matter what,
look fresh and you'll be surprised how
your mind take over your realized later
on you're not really tired and when
you're tired keep pushing because the next
time you usually get tired around that
three minute mark it and make it to about
the seven,
eight minutes.
There's like 15 and you start doing those
grime managers and you'd go 30 minutes
lie and when it's done I'm able to walk,
shake,
code your hand and go grab another
partner or we'll get on the treadmill is
because we always push as a big guy.
So you've got to imagine when I came
down to two oh five it was like, yeah,
it was crazy. Like this is, this is
like magic. I can do this all day.
Coach fired rounds at first.
Jim,
my five round fight with Jimmy when
they called my boss the main event.
Now you got to train six rounds like okay,
like it was moving the cage.
We did three rounds mark like you know
you're doing six a day. That's fine.
Gave me three new partners went and
they was tired and I'll still good like,
dude, your cardio was a
crazy, it's just a mentor.
Even when I'm tired I'll never show it.
He's like,
I just got to act fresh and get
through it. It can only last so long.
My father told me I forever.
It is a weird thing, isn't it? That
your mind can give you more energy.
Like you know that feeling that sometimes
you're on a treadmill or something
like that and you're running and a
great song comes on and all of a sudden
you're like, Woo. You like feel it.
Like you got like all of a sudden extra
like where's it every time it's coming
from your mind, your mind. I
wouldn't beat the uptown pumping.
Are you to start dancing while you're
running in like three to five minutes.
I have a loan.
That song gets you like on a sprint.
Then once that song and then you really
feel it, the tone change. Ah, Shit.
I'm tired of it. Crazy
isn't it? That that's some,
there's a switch in your mind that you
almost like you have to figure out where
it is. You gotta go find it
and a song can find it for you.
But like for you just to be able to pull
it out like especially in a fight or
something like that when you battle and
doubt and this and that and you know,
you're how he's doing,
you know, is he okay? Is he tired?
Am I on who's tired or me or him,
you know?
And there's that switch in your mind that
if you could just access that all the
time and keep it on.
One of the things,
I think one of the guys I looked up
to when I was in college, you know,
he was past Steve Prefontaine as well.
I just store all the time.
It's quotes to do anything. Anything
listening at best is a waste of a gift.
You know he ran, he didn't, it
was cross country, but Gosh Trot,
they pacing and everyday
he said I'm running to like
I'm sprinting. You're like,
I watched all his movies, the
movies on him. Cause mindset.
Even at one race when he was
philosopher and they say it's hard,
it's going to give.
He gave out right before the finish line.
Like I'd rather go out that way.
Then pacing my whole the whole time it
didn't try to sprint in and fail because
I wasn't ready so that's like in
my fight I started off so fast.
That's just I'm going all out.
There's no fill out period.
We're going to touch gloves.
I'm ready to move and I already
know like if I'm getting tired,
I know this guy is getting tired.
He's not trained like I'm training
and if he is training I'm training.
He might not be type of my mind.
I'm thinking he's getting tired and just
keep pushing because eventually he's
going to break.
He's going to break before me.
Now do you have a system in terms of
like your strength and conditioning
program? Do you, do you have
a schedule that you follow?
Like Lex verse specifically for however
many weeks you have before your fight?
When I get in a fight camp, everything
get really specific. Like I said,
Eric on aerial show him, um,
calculating which camp sign.
Like don't mess my order. I like, I'll be
early, I had my bags packed night before.
I have three, four training bags packed
at the right at the little edge x way.
So when I come home and I'm sure we're
running short on time, running late,
grab something, eat, grab the
next bag and locked the door.
And I know where I got to go. I hate
when people have to cancer. Like,
oh I can't make it today.
Or if something came up or I show up,
my partner don't show up. You're not on
time. I'm like, I'm on. The guy's like,
I'm kind of like the
leader of the big guys.
Like we're going to be here earlier this
week so we can start at 10 30 cause I
want to do drills after we're going
to do this. You need to work on that.
I'm very punctual. I hate it when
it's camp time of you showing up late.
I hate it. It Kinda, it
runs me ragged and I just,
when we spar I kind of take
it out on people. I just,
I'm very calculated when it comes to
camp because this is my career. You know,
I'm serious about this. I'm not showing up
late. Like I go to boxing gyms, we guys,
and we've always sparring at six o'clock
so I show up at five 45 or six 45 they
still not there when he put
walking like nothing's wrong.
Talking and dance was like,
Yo, you said six o'clock right?
Like you're a professional ain't,
you will quit acting like an amateur.
Get here on time. Let's go. This
is your camp. I'm here to help you.
Even that makes me mad. But
when it's my camp, you show up.
It's not fun because I know I'm not going
to get tired so I'm just going to beat
on me. Who writes out? You're scared.
Do you write it out or did
you just know what it is?
Do you have it in your hand or
write it out? You write it down?
Well I put like a notepad and I put how
many weeks now pull it out and I try to
early into it. Like when I first start, I
give it like an ideal what I want to do.
So Tuesday, Thursdays during
the conditioning on Monday,
Friday string the conditioning before
Jujitsu, what? Ricardo. And then Tuesday,
Thursday I'm doing one
on ones with Ricardo.
And Wednesday I'm gonna do my one on
one with Nica tone. And then, excuse me,
Tuesday night or Monday night,
I'm going to admit some mark.
And then Saturday I have to spar,
I do another Mitt,
tried to two of everything and I go up
to Rutgers and wrestle because in Jersey
everything has such a commute. So you
have the time, everything's perfect.
Cause if practice goes 15 minutes
pass or whatever or somebody is late,
that's messing me up cause I got to
drive an hour to 45 minutes to get to the
next place and I'm running
late for that practice.
Or if it's three practice in the row and
I get there just a little bit right on
time. I don't have time to get ready to
do my full warm up to make sure my body's
warm, then get to the next spot under
the same thing. Now I'm rushing.
Nah It's not stopped and I gotta get
home and grab something to eat quick.
I've got to keep my food with me and
it's getting cold and this is like I,
I'm very punctual in specific
when it comes to stuff like that.
Do you meal prep? Do you have like a
little Tupperware containers with food?
Just grab one and I used to use, why
not use, I still use eat clean bro.
When you get into camp, let's use them
all the time. But now like I said,
I got to call, I eat clean
bro Clean Bro. It's a Jamie,
I can't remember his last name, but Jamie
and New Jersey named, he's killing it,
man. He Dj Khaled. Uh,
c'mon. Camella, Anthony La.
All all the famous people use them.
He just opened up another one in Atlanta.
He's killing the game with the meal
prep and he's, it's good. It's accurate.
It wasn't as accurate before they teamed
up with this company revolutionized
which the nutrition coming.
They do the calculation of all the
meals for fighters and different people.
Bodybuilders and it's perfect, but it
has all your nutrients, all your protein.
It has it set up like this is 40 grams
of protein and then you can also go in
there and just ordered a raw stuff.
They give it dead and they delivered
to your door and then you just cook it.
Yeah, you can get it raw and
they'll put it in the freezer bag.
You get it and just put it
in. I know people that do it
that way. Like I said, not.
I have my wife who fights and she or he
used to fight and she knows what's going
on. Most of the time she does that for
me. You know, if you bring them venison,
will they cook that?
And I know he told me if I get a
Turkey he would cook it up for me.
So I'm sure he'd give me some venison
if I cooked me best and if I took it to
him. Now when you say you have
everything set up, um, uh,
you monitoring your heart rate,
like what do you,
what are you doing to make sure that
you're not overtrained or that's saying
that's one of the thing. I'm still not,
I'm not really dancing with it and my mom,
I'm fine with it because growing up my
coach is telling all the time those such
thing over training is a mental state.
You know, as long as you train, eat,
rest, you're giving your body
time to rest and recover,
get to bed by a certain time so you get
at least seven, eight hours of sleep.
It's Kinda hard to overtrain.
But those days where you feel you hurting
like shoulders, like when my injuries,
it's okay to dial back when we go to
the gym. You don't have to hit it hard,
just go through the
motions sometimes like,
oh don't be here to go
through the motions.
But sometimes it ain't bad to go through
the motions as long as you're focused
on one thing to master,
just take down a master,
this sweep of mass that you just
submission on a sweep or whatever it is,
focus on it and going nice and slow,
calculate.
You don't have to get a sweat every
time cause you learn muscle memory,
do it a thousand times. And now it's Kinda
like it's in there. I got it. But um,
with the overtraining and heart reminder,
I only heart monitor further the last
five to six weeks because that's when I
hit cardio heart. Not so much strength
anymore, but pushing the pace,
everything I'm doing blowing out and try
to keep my heart rate above a certain
thing. So if the last day before
I go into that, it's pace,
I put the heart rate monitor
on and see wherever I got you.
I don't take much of a break
between my trainers, my stations,
see what my heart rate got. So the high
was one 72 today or whatever. All right.
So that's the high on a slow day and
it's hard for me to get my heart rate up.
So it's like when we do doing Carter,
I'm shooting for like one eighties after
everything I need to be above that.
So I take time for it to come down.
So in between that 30 to a minute break,
if I'm still right there at one
81 70 so I'm, I hit the next one.
I know my heart is still racing so I'm
stretching my lungs out and take the
little short break and I never do
a full minute break even in spawn.
So in fighting,
that's why and that minute you see me
talking to Mark Henry and everything is
there like, Oh of course
having a conversation in
between around mark Costes.
I'm like, Yep, Yep. Okay, I'm going to
Jujitsu marks and I said, I'm trying,
I hear you because that's how we train
and practice on that short clock.
A longer time, work, shorter time,
recover am tired and
practice at the beginning.
But at the end is kind of like going
into the fight that last week we talk and
we smile and we chill. It go
round this and this is, you
got to do this. All right,
well we got to do better this time
did I had to sweep right there.
That's the mission.
What was wrong with my hands and the
next one I work on this again and to be
able to communicate and not be tired.
It makes a world of difference.
Do you give yourself 30 seconds
and training? It depends.
Depends on who we fighting.
It depends on my mentality.
You know half I feel like there's going
to be a hard day if we ain't got the
clock.
Sometimes I have it on my phone.
If the coach is not there and my wife
doing it and I stand up and I feel like
I'm recovering like 20 minutes or
20 seconds start go. And I was just,
we got to keep rotating my partner.
So cause I know they can't recover
all the time, but it's just like I'm,
I'm a little different, you know? It's
like always thinking outside the box. I'm,
I'm trying to do with
the other people aren't,
I mean you know everybody going off like
a dolce diet or the Keto diet or such
and such training or west
side barbell or this and that.
That's kind of like I take the different
stuff I learned from this guy and I saw
from this guy I learned in wrestling,
I seen on youtube and I heard somebody
say it is like I wonder if I can just
take away and take a little bit of this,
put it a little bit with
the west side Barbell,
put it with the Keto Diet along with
my own business and die and this,
this and this and just try it out.
And if it works it works.
And if I don't feel good, I feel low
energy. He's a guy that doesn't work,
I'm going to try something different.
It seems like a lot of people
would want to listen to you though.
I was imagining if I was in camp with
a guy like you and I saw the kind of
cardio that you have for a big guy and
the amount of effort that you put in.
I would imagine there's other dudes that
are following you now. No, my teammates.
Yeah, they know like I'm one of
the guys, my like a brother to me,
his car Roverson you seen,
he stepped,
he stepped up on the glorify and that's
something we talked about when he was an
amateur. I've been working with us,
they're like amateur and I told his coach,
they're like, this kid is good,
he's got the right stuff. He go pro.
He being UFC and no time. You suddenly,
cause he was, I watched him, me,
him and Chris Weidman.
He came in with us when I was helping.
Why more to Rockhold fight and I've cut,
I'm not sure if he was
an amateur or pro yet,
but he was hanging his Jujitsu and
her husband, he didn't have that.
But striking was, he was
giving us problems. It was
like this is, this kid is good.
He's a glory kickboxing. Huh. That
makes sense. He kicks hard. I'm like,
I haven't seen him put many people just
sleep with his head kick in practice
like Yo pull it. He's like, Bro, that
wasn't even hard. Like what's your mean?
I wasn't hung.
He's like,
I just flicked it up there but he's
just so explosive and athletic.
He hit me with a need what?
Last Saturday and my chest steal hurt
cause I got shot and he caught me coming
down and shot and I was like, Oh shit.
But I was in deep but he just so quick.
It's just, but like he's one, he hits me
up all the time. Come to camp like Yo,
he has died down because of
bow and clip out of the Pie.
You ended up going to come back to work
and stuff. Should we keep doing this?
Should we do this? I'm going to run today.
So when I want to work on my Jujitsu,
what should I do? This I just drill.
Should we go hard? Should I go here?
Sometimes the performance
institute in Vegas.
Well, every time we
get a camp, me and him,
we got to think of one of us getting
can't we already know I'm a contact him.
You got to fight when we going to Vegas.
So I go,
we go out there for a week or two weeks,
meet him and Rex Harris,
he goes in the pff because other bass
pros, only three dudes at USC and Jersey.
We didn't have traveled around.
We'd been to Vegas.
We've been to Arizona or wherever we go
and we go hard and that's why we call it
basketball. There's no, oh we going to
light today Bro, don't hit me every time.
It's like, well you ready? You
Ready? Rex actually texted me.
We was going to take them
off. He was like, yeah,
I'll be there tomorrow because I'm
flying here and I get back in time for
training. So Bass Bros meet
up and we go at it. That's it.
Are you,
are you always sparring hard?
Well, we, we got certain days, like
if we don't want to spoil heart,
we know not to go with each other because
it's kind of like if one week I get
the best of wrecks,
like there's been times like I had car
off or we're OSP cause he's south and
he's super good.
I won't recall three rounds heart.
So his main focus was takedown.
No let them up.
So I take him down and beat him
on the ground, feet on the ground,
take him down and beat him on the ground
cause he didn't have wrestling at the
time. And then he would go
with like somebody else,
like I need one more around
and he'd be mad. I know that,
but that's why I'm not
going home on the fourth,
fourth round cause he's mad and he'd go
out there with somebody else and just,
you just eat him up and she's like,
I'm sorry, I have to apologize.
The other guy like, I'm sorry if I'm
beating him up because the hostility.
So we go hard, but there's times we
pulled other guys and you're like,
I'm gonna call this amateur guy in pretty
good amateur or a low level pro pro.
Some guys that Eddie Alvarez
knows whenever I got this kid,
he's pro two oh five he's the beginner.
Whatever you want to work with him,
that's the guy. I bring them up today.
I'm gonna do a technical move day,
kind of like wall work,
drilling, we sparring.
We have had your own just in
case cause accidents happen.
But nothing is strong with
intention to hurt anybody.
What'd you have a fantastic camp too,
man.
It was one of the most unheralded camps.
If you want to talk about who's training
out there that beat you guys have
Marlin,
you know,
of course Frankie Edgar means so
many guys come from that area.
Eddie Alvarez,
you and I mean it's just mark Henry's
one of the most underappreciated guys in
MMA I think because he's so quiet and
unassuming. Doesn't toot his own horn.
But when you talk to that guy, you see
the wheel spin and you're like, wow,
he something serious.
And everybody I know that's worked
with them and said he's like one of
the best coaches I've ever, ever seen.
Nothing like it. I remember the
first time I went, he broke it down.
I remember he was telling
me movement on his show.
He broke me down a little bit like we're
going to work like they'll punch slide
out, slide back, slide clinch, different
stuff, staying out of punching range.
He brought me down very lightly for six
weeks and like I fell in love with it
there. Is that the first time you worked
as far as you asked him to this day when
wisdom the back, the first fight to get
in the house and I was the last fight.
I told my coach I like to warm early
isn't so I want to start warming up before
the first fight just
to get my heart going.
It was the rest of the thing go heart
and he just chilled so time and I,
when I was going here like have you ever
done this before? I had no background,
anything, just a restaurant. I could
throw a one tooth. That was it.
And he was like,
I'm going to show you this.
And he kept telling me to do it
and I was listening like, Bro,
you're listen so well. Like one of
the wrestling, you have to listen.
And that's when me and
Mark Click from that day,
and I remember when they flipped
a coin and it came off Freaky,
seen Frankie get the first pick.
I remember hearing marketing back court,
we won't core, he listens.
He's a writer and be a mark,
have been like this since
and we have that bond.
But I remember coming the first day
of the House I got the Jersey is,
that's how I got there. Mark was the
one, it takes me Frankie route say,
oh come on Ricardo.
I met everybody together.
But mark was the one that was more hands
on texting me while I was back home
with the family work.
This work that work,
this work that go to roof for
sport and work your kicks.
We need to have the kicks.
Good. By the time we get here.
And it was in the basement.
It's like, all right,
so you see like this whole piece of
paper, like all the way down, like coats,
everybody's Co's wrote on that
paper and what does that, he's like,
oh that's the combos. Like that's like a
hundred combos. Like oh hey we got co's.
Like nobody ever knows this.
It only changes the code
for each fight, right? Yeah.
And I'm like, what is that? And you
see my papers just blink cause the guy,
so this is just schedule. He had me
on the first code, it's just schedule.
And that was pat like 13 weeks
of nonstop going. It's like,
and this is what we're going
to work for your coast.
So today we're going
to start with the Jab,
cross ski to codes for that and movement
about three rounds. And I was like, Yo,
like I'm flat footed. I couldn't
move. Like I can't do this. He's like,
you could do it.
It's like a tandem dance.
And we joined a dance team and the
first day we learned this new routine.
We're going to be all over with
tripping each other every day.
And the next day we get a
little better in a week.
We got to kind of like the first,
the first course we got it.
By the end of the time it was time to
perform. We're going to look beautiful,
I promise you. And sure enough he, he uh,
I found he had a piece of your
like I want to slice a pizza.
It's like I want you to learn how to
move. He's like, you learn how to move.
I'll give you a slice of my pieces.
He said, when you can move out,
bring you a slice of pizza. I heard
he's got some killer ps pretty good.
I think like it was a week 10 before
the fight I had 13 we can't like you,
you actually moved a little bit.
I told my wife to bring you on slides.
It was slides like I got his approval
and ever since then like it's just been a
thing that movement his, his scientific
ways. Yeah. Like I've seen Chris,
why I'm and do it.
Rashad Evans,
we got Lance Palmer and
Claudia now different people
like watching and trying to
learn. You can just see, oh, last is out
there too now. He just came out recently.
He was last week when I, before I
left, he showed us out there. Who Will?
Claudia [inaudible].
She had a gym out there and she's been
at our gym working and when mark was like
helping him after sparring last Thursday
and he called me in the case like Corey,
he's really good to
show them how we do the the one,
two blah blah blah.
And like when I look back and they both
had that look at each other like, uh,
that was a lot of shit. But you
figure it out in time when it's new.
Anything new you,
it's going to be uncomfortable.
But after you figure it out and you
do it for so much, it's muscle memory.
So when you were fighting as
a heavyweight, you weren't
a mover. I mean what?
I thought it was moving,
I wasn't moving,
but for heavyweight it was just kind of
like a little bounce bounce my knees.
If they go to step forward,
when I go to a punch,
hop out and then come back
with a jab to a AA. Right.
That's what I had to meander chair.
That was movement. I was the man,
I'm moving my ass off.
No, that was nothing.
You get the mark and it's kind of
like feet on your toe spot a spot.
Don't ever stop when you stop me. He be
like 10 times like that's what happened.
We stopped.
It's really interesting when you watch
the difference between the way people
utilize footwork. I think probably
the best example and combat,
well there's two great
examples in combat sports.
Lama Chanko who has got some of the
most incredible footwork of all time and
Sanchez who, who's a toy town,
who's got crazy foot work,
constantly switching stances,
light on his toes,
fights different than any other tie
fighter and widely considered the best of
all time, you know, and Loma Chanko.
Like when you watch guys who
have good footwork fight him.
They like what in the fuck?
Like you throw a punch and he's over
here and he's hitting you here and upper
cuts coming under your armies.
He's back this way and he's like
the matrix constantly moving.
And that guy started out as a dancer.
His Dad when he was,
his dad was training him out of box.
He made him do Russian folk dancing I
think I want to say for like four years.
He made him do this, this kind of
Russian style of dancing. He was like,
you got to,
you're going to have to learn how to
move your feet and now you see him.
He fights.
It's effortless.
It's just a part of who he is and guys
who are like more plotting and they're
used to that normal stationary target.
He's so much more complex and you see
any obviously fantastic punch or two,
but the footwork is off the charts.
It's just such a different thing.
There's levels to everything.
And you I guess realize that when you
went from heavyweight to train with mark
mark yet, but like when we
said the footwork thing,
one thing I seen uh, an MMA,
the Holloway or Tigger fight.
Yeah,
I feel like it in my mind I felt like
I was watching and lemon, chicken, MMA,
how Holloway was like hidden angles
because Brian isn't like a mover type.
He just, he's biting down, he's gritty,
he's ready to go and it seemed
like as the round like third,
fourth and fifth or
third and fourth round.
Like when he would go to punch
macro switched South Paul. Yup.
I'll hop out and when he go to Kauai and
go back with the hook this way and it
was just like, Yo, his
footwork right now is like,
I watched probably like seven times.
It's studying his feet. Like how was,
he ain't never lost balance. One time
it was like this is just incredible.
I love watching it.
Like it's a dance.
It's beauty now max is very good
at distinct distance control.
He's one of the very best at just
moving slightly out of range.
Then right back in and he puts a lot
of pressure on you because of the two.
There's no,
if he catches you
breathing heavy and he kept his,
if he sees any slowing down in you,
he starts pouring it on like you started
to try and get you to wilt. He sees it.
It's very, very interesting how he
does it too because he does it with,
he overloads you not just with his attack
but also with all the variables that
you see.
The combinations of switching,
the putting pressure on
you just as there's so much
going on that you're always
thinking about it and it's does that
on top of it makes you more tired.
He's good at smelling the
blood. Yeah, he's good. He
knows a lot of people. I know.
That's one thing I'm not good at.
I'm working on,
mark was telling me other day like I want
to start finish people with the hands.
Like you had so many
places where you couldn't,
but you hit a guy with a common or
you take a shot like the Gavi. Right.
You just don't see it and instead
of key punching him, you as shoot,
he stopped punching your chute on him.
It's like I hit guy the combos and like
when I go to the boss and you're like,
Bro,
you box like you a boxer but you're going
to be a fight and you box just to get
you your take downs. But
that's because I'm a wrestler.
I can box. I don't have to,
but I will.
Do you think there's a worry though when
you're trying to finish fights versus
just trying to fight your best?
I think guys should just fight their
best and if the finished comes, it comes.
I'm of the opinion that I'm of the opinion
that when people make big mistakes,
and I wouldn't discourage anybody from
going crazy if someone likes to go crazy,
they like to fight wild. Hey man,
that's you. That's your style.
That's how you express yourself.
Nothing wrong with it.
But if I was going to give some advice
and they said, what should I do?
I want to have a long career as a
professional. Let's say fight your best.
Don't worry about the outcome.
Just fight your best.
And if you fight your
best and if you connected,
someone gets hurt and you put them
away, that's great. But if you just win,
that's great to just fight your best.
The more,
the more you can do what you can
technically and take as little damage as
possible. That's a good fight. And this,
that's almost the OSP fight.
Mark said it like you just got to,
has got whole camp.
He's got that good kit and then the Osp
Fi and Gian volante the two fights and
mark called the only thing that I can
get knocked out way. He said, well Gee,
I'm blind to it. The only thing that's
gonna knock you out, what is overhead,
right?
He says,
you got to bring that jab right back
after he got a good job of bringing your
hands back. Cause he's
times that overhand. Right?
So smooth and even in between rounds
like you, you know where I am, right?
I know it's not hurting you but only takes
one. It takes one. Keep that hand up.
Keep that hand up.
And sure enough till this day he say,
remember I told you overhand,
right? And then with Osp is like,
only thing I can get you is that, hey,
that left kick. If you stay close to him,
keep the pressure, keep them on
occasion when he's down, he stand up,
bring them back down.
Don't listen to the fans.
People are going to get to your
head and make you want to strike.
Trying to get in that fight.
That's what they want to see.
But we just try and get the win.
Don't go right and keep pressure,
not go right and keep pressure.
If you watched that fight,
the whole two rounds pressure
and not going right, going left,
put them to the case, taking him down,
keep them down in the KT, stand up,
bring them back. Third round, I took him
down, he Pato and I was against the case.
I can remember her if he was say,
oh,
they'll stand up and and stand up and
fight and I backed away for a second,
started moving like, God, I'm going
to play from the outside a little bit.
And I went right. Trying to the
Hickey and I was like, when I came,
first thing mark said in the bay, I bro,
you look phenomenal. You just went right,
like you look great. You just went
right. Everything was beautiful. A fight.
That was your breakthrough
fight. You, you just went right,
but we're going to go back. You
going to do better. I know you will.
And now it's just like after that I
guess I went to John boy was like,
fuck what the fans say we've went in.
But like you said, when you and Shabazz,
when I listened to before and you
say I'd be little chief, I beat this,
but you don't hear my name is because
I'm not trying to do this stuff that's
exciting anymore. I'm just winning
and my style and exciting to them.
But that's because you're
not a mixed martial arts fan.
You're a fan of a knockout or
you're a fan of some fancy stuff.
They talk in Johnny Walker up.
This isn't this.
Johnny Walker hasn't shown
mixed martial arts shit.
He's shown it fancy stuff that not
people out. It looks great. Yes,
but just like Anthony
Smith and all those guys,
when they get in front of somebody like
John Jones and you can't hit him with
that one punch, what are you
going to do? You know what I mean?
So that's thing I'll say right
now. I'm not fighting. He said,
when are you going to fight?
I don't know,
but I'll be ready cause
I can do everything.
Yeah, we were just talking about Johnnie
Walker. He's in surgery now. Who are,
he had to go through surgery for show.
Showed that that celebration,
that celebration was just so crazy.
He wins.
He beat beat circa runoff
with a beautiful time knee.
Perfect flying knee looks fantastic and
then drops to the ground just playing
around and blows his fucking shoulder out.
It's crazy.
That's the game or anything can happen.
And then when it was 10 injury,
what happens like that? It's like God
damn man, you're so promising. Um, he's a,
he's a mean. What, what gets people
excited when people finish fights, right?
People Kao People. And so a lot of
times people try to lean towards that.
But if that's not your style,
you know you should,
you should fight the way your
f if I was in your corner,
first of all I'd say listen to Mark Henry,
Mark Henry knows everything.
And then second of all,
I would say don't change shit man.
What you're doing is perfect.
Just just fight the way you're fighting,
the way you're fighting is just you
winning. You know you're, you're,
I just think that it should be what it
should be emphasized always to fight the
best.
You can fight intelligently and you got
to decide and everybody has to decide
when is it time to take a risk,
when is it time to close the distance?
When is it time to put
pressure on someone and,
and throw yourself into the
fire to try to get a finish.
And if you just think you should
just fight technically, look man,
fucking Floyd Mayweather has
done that most of his career,
especially like later on when he was
pretty boy Floyd earlier on his career.
He's trying to knock a lot of guys out.
But later on in his career and most of
his big fights like with Pacquiao and a
lot of the guys,
he just wins.
He just wins and it makes more
money than anybody just wins.
Interesting. Um, and my mind,
I know exactly, I'll tell
you when I get in this bar,
no spelling is not want to work on things.
You know every,
every Saturday going to spot me and my
wife's Josh like what are you on today
we're going to try to work on,
put a little more emphasis on the punches
and not shoot right away and blah blah
blah on the ground.
More ground and pound on.
Worry about did just Jujitsu submission.
Just hit this, this and this.
When it's come time to fight,
when the lights come on Saturday night
and Joe are Bruce buffer in there and you
sit down the side, it's a whole different
game plan. I know what I can do.
I know what's right and that's why I get
into those spots and like I tell myself,
take a shot. It's muscle
memory. When I hit him,
he put his hands up and he stopped
the legs wide open course. Oh,
the NCAA all American, uh, NCAA finalist.
Why we're not, shoot, I'd take them down.
Exactly. And if he's looking
at my last three fights,
I feel like going back and watching them,
those,
you can't say I'm one side because
at lear everybody will know way.
He can rest with lear. Lear is way
more powerful and better. Russell,
he works with photo. Uh, whatever
worries from Albanian world team.
He couldn't take me down
and I'll struggle. You know,
you went to glove like, oh,
glow over to finish. You've just,
who got core goes to ground him.
It's over and he can not Cory out.
I was struggling.
I'll rest of them and got them in mount
and had him Seigel. I had him, his head,
his back. I had every position on him.
So you can't say I don't have Jujitsu,
I don't have restaurant,
don't have striking cause
near and impact comes there.
But like, oh, he was an
Ncaa d one. All American.
This isness he beat DC at OTC. He had
beaks on a kill Korean restaurant. Stop.
Just take down and set the record with
13 takedowns on him who had the record at
11 it's like I don't understand the fans.
Everybody got something to say,
but if you listen to people too much,
Cari, my wife said all the time,
like every morning like no
negativity today. Fuck off line.
That's what you should do.
Cause I'm doing a hunting
stuff and I'll pose this stuff.
It's like as I'm going to put
it, it pops on my pop up. Yeah.
Or at the top of the screen it had dropped
down or pop up in the notification or
I get an email notification. Somebody
say, hey, you see half of it.
I like the open door that
I drive and I want her.
The rest of us say it
could be a good thing.
It might be bad and actually open it up
later on if somebody saying something bad
like my wife just said, she's like, I see
it. Just don't pay no attention to it.
Yeah,
you're, you're allowing negativity
into life that you don't need. I mean,
you think about your camp,
you got all these positive people,
all these motivated people, all
these professionals, you know,
exceptional human beings,
right?
Everybody training and grind together
and then you got schmoes that are
contacting you on Twitter or Instagram
or whatever and just saying a bunch of
nonsense and that could fuck
with your head. You know?
And these are not people that would ever
say that if they were in front of your
face. It's a gross way to communicate.
It's just, it's not a hell. It's like,
it's like passing by a shitty fast food
restaurant being drawn in to eat and
then you eat and you're like,
God, why did he take the garbage?
It's the same thing. It's
like you're eating, it's like
fast food for your brain.
It's, it's so tempting because you
just want to read those comments.
And most of the people are probably
good people who are fans, most of them.
But all it takes is 10% assholes.
And you never want to look
at your comments again.
One out of 10 and this is not hard to
get 10% and 10% assholes. It's like
pretty damn good in the real world.
You know,
if you only run into one out of 10
that's an asshole or one out of a hundred
even if it was one out of a hundred
and your comments have shitty,
you don't want to read those comments.
It's just for a fighter man.
It's so much of it is about mindset and
just being focused and not having any
distractions. And I think those comments
are a giant distraction. You know,
you don't need anybody telling you what
to teach you how to mark fucking Henry
you. You've got Ricardo Elmeda, you've
got all these world champions around you,
like you don't need any,
any other information.
You're getting plenty of information,
you know, fuck all that shit.
You shouldn't even look at it.
You should post and just run away.
Just post something and don't even
look out. Keep going. Just keep going.
Just you got to work it.
I know I've got to work on it
because what you're saying right now,
all of the things you were saying about
beating Glover about beating a clearly
TFA yet, but you're saying it
like you're arguing with somebody.
You're saying like,
someone told you you can't do it,
but who gives a fuck what
they said you did do it.
So why argue with someone who clearly
doesn't know what the fuck they're talking
about anyway, right. But in
your head and you're like,
they said I couldn't do this. They
like, see you still have that. It's,
he know what I'm talking about.
That battle hundred percent good mark.
And they tell me all the time
like, Bro, quick feed, like
don't, don't even read it.
I come from smart,
me and my brother,
we always had that mentality like people
were like, we're talking to, isn't this?
Yeah, we weren't as active. We ain't going
to sit there and talk back and forth.
It was like my first responding to
anybody. He's talking shit like, Hey,
put your hands up. I'm ready to
fight. I'm gonna prove you wrong.
That's all my time. Like they always
say it, Corey couldn't do this.
You will do that. You when did this my
whole life like in college, like court,
you're not going to go to Midlands.
We only take five guys on the teen and
young guarantee coaching going to take
you where the two years I was there I was
the guy that went to the middle of the
first pick every time like I'm always
shooting to prove somebody wrong.
Do you feel like that's a
part of your motivation? Yes.
It's always been that way.
But you're also,
your motivation is obviously excellent
so there's no way it could just be to
prove someone wrong as hard as you
work. No, but that's just, let's put it,
that's how I got to the mentality
and the work ethic I guess.
Cause in high school I wasn't like this.
I sucked in high school I lost way.
I didn't win a match.
I was sophomore in high school.
I'm a wrestler since third grade.
Like I was asked tastic and
horrible like why got beat one time?
And the coach left me out.
They left,
they load the bus and left
me sitting there because you
got beat the way. Upbeat.
Yes. They didn't want to bring you
home. It wasn't, I got beat through.
I got dropped off. So a girl, Joe.
Ooh, you lost to a girl. Dead Ass.
I didn't have the mental,
I logged up when I got out the Mat,
the team was gone when outside the bus
was going on. The reason I got home,
because the varsity came for it,
do it at night. And he was like,
why are you still here?
Wow. That's fucked up. Yeah.
That's something ruthless
coach. But that's the thing.
I wasn't, I was that boy,
like he got the little boy
that cried wolf. You know,
I was always trying to get
out of workouts. I was fat.
I was lazy at the time.
Growing up, I loved outdoors. I love video
games and I love eating junk. You know,
I didn't always have this mindset. So when
it came to a point I wanted to do good
and I was trying and took my first injury.
I very first injury sophomore year in
high school before Congress I snapped my
ankle cleanser and I remember
everybody when I was in a hurt,
first time I was actually hurting,
but I have fixed so many injuries.
Even a coach came up with
like, cool, y'all was faking.
Everybody's wearing run sprints.
You get up because they all thought I
was faking but I was actually hurt and my
buddy stopped by,
he grabbed me and took me to his trainer
in to train is like when I was probably
a spring here, be fine. Once the dog,
my dad came and got me and
winter he did an x Ray,
I'm up there was like this much
bone holding my foot from Pharma.
They like ain't cool is like pretty
much I why know nobody bring you in.
Like they kept saying it was nothing
wrong and I went back to the x.
It was all like, oh bro, I'm so sorry.
Like you have been like for so
long and residents third grade,
you know I did it because my brother
did it and I went do everything he did,
but I didn't, I didn't have the
drive he had. But after that scene,
the way everybody kind of like dog me out,
I remember coming back from recovery
from that and the first time I ran after
injury and even in my mind like I
can't run this, I can't really get,
and I did and I was limping.
I was scared it was gonna break again.
But I made it to where I was going.
Like Brock and dude, this is just,
it's all here now. That's my
real, everything goes mentality.
Like I never had any problems. I was
just lazy. I didn't want to work.
So I was finding a way out. Now that
the next year you can ask the coaches,
they told my parents I got moved up
to the varsity tournament the first or
second match and I catch the second and
third and the varsity tournament after
wrestling Jv for the year before. And
I lost the guy that, one of the things,
there's a difference between core now is
night and day is because I realized if
I put my mind to it and just work,
quit wearing my dad said it too.
That's the thing my dad puts it on.
So you're at such a young age.
My brother got it.
He was a star athlete,
but he didn't get the openings in
the opportunities I had. You know,
cause he's always working for my
father and working here, working there.
He didn't have the time to do camps
and all that. Me being the youngest,
it was a little easier for me.
I seen when he did what he told me,
when my brothers,
my sisters and teammates and all the
different different people around me had
done. I knew the way I needed to go to
get somewhere. But being a star athlete,
a professional athlete, it was never a
goal of mine. I wanted to be engineered.
I love building club houses and Shit
like that. That was what I wanted to do.
But all of that open doors. I wanted to
go to school to University of Wisconsin,
Platteville for an engineer program,
but just like sports, my grazers ass,
I didn't see,
I didn't try and so I went there to
hang out with my friends and be cool.
You know what I mean? When I applied,
they messaged me back saying,
your GPA isn't good enough.
The restaurant culture on the media.
Because by then I was good at wrestling.
My last few years I killed it.
I never made the state,
but I killed in the regional and sections.
I will all of the sections and
lost in the finals. He had to go,
you have to when they're a third whatever.
But um, and it says you can't get here,
but you got to go to junior college. You
get your GPA up, we can get you in again.
I went there. I didn't plan on
wrestling anymore. I loved wrestling.
I cry when it was over. But then, um, the
Guy Dave Clem, man, he uses old coach.
That's how I met Matt Hughes to Lincoln
College. He reached out to me. I was like,
I heard about you. You got the mentality
of a like you work hard, your workhorse.
I need somebody like you to
come here and work for me.
I can't get a scholarship because you
didn't do much. I don't have money left.
I gave you 1800 bucks. It was 27,000 I
thought it was like a full ride. I'm like,
Oh Sean, get money. And
I went, they're excited,
determined to get there and
everybody like, Oh yeah,
you know we made a state not going to
do good. This isn't this. So again,
that was motivation from right there going
to school like they don't think I can
do this date on.
My grades aren't good enough.
They don't think I can get education.
I'm not good enough for sports.
I don't think I'm all American.
I think I'm gonna go down and just be
another member of the team. I went there,
I cut up but row for a season
snapped my leg in three.
I thought it was over again.
And that coaches,
like I saw you fire a different
leg injury at the same,
the same leg with different
injury for like three years later.
You're back to the first one that
injuries. What changed you? Well,
I got tired of people was
thinking I was faking.
So because you were injured for real
in people thought you were faking it,
you realize something was wrong.
I feel that I realized I have been
lazy and my father and my whole life.
You go to my old house right now in
the garage. It's steel carved in there.
I never get day. It was probably like
eight o'clock nine o'clock school night.
My Dad woke me and my brother to help
him do some stuff on a boat. We tired,
you know, we want to go back and we out
there complaining the whole time. He says,
my dad, if you've met my dad is
the most motivating person ever.
Don't have an education. None. But he,
he started his own business
from the ground up and he's
living the dream hunting
properties for everyone. He can do
it and that's where I got it from.
But it took me forever to realize this
and I'll never forget the day says it
comes to me all the time.
I think about,
he stood up on the boat and was up
against the garage door, brand new garage.
So he just put up, you know, one
thing I hate, I cannot stand is lazy.
And he took his drill,
he cut l a Z,
y and the back of his brand new garage
and it's still there till this day I go
home and I visited.
I go there and you'll see it cut in
and do it lazy and he cannot stand it.
And if you know him the way he works,
he's just turned 59 Tuesday and I could
and his voice and I said, you had a job.
So I don't know. Oh He's, they
are working. He got a bunch
of 20 year olds, 30 year.
He outworks everybody 59
years of up and down a ladder.
Brian Crane driving the truck
to the shot and that's it.
He always said when I was a kid saying,
can only last so long.
I never understood what he said. He used
to come up to me on the football field.
I'd be crying and moping around. It can
only last so long so can keep going.
I can only last so long. I said like,
what do you mean? Why you always say that?
And then later on it started getting hard.
I started thinking like practice
going and looking at the clock.
It's like 45 minutes but can only last
so long and it clicked like, oh shit.
That's what my dad meant all these years
it can only last so long line. Just go,
just go. Just put your nose. I get to,
so you have this injury sophomore year,
your ankle snaps and you realize
that you've been lazy. So what?
What shifted in your mind? What
did, how did you change it?
Just stop worrying about excuses to get
out of practice and the first graduate
as I was healing,
I was on bedrest for awhile.
It was so bad and people come in out and
my brother used to come over at a time
he was playing football and
whatever and watching his games.
It's just like sitting there for so long
away from all the sports and all your
friends and just sitting there just
yourself. And I just realized like I can,
I've been doing it since third grade.
I've seen this stuff a million times.
I know the moves, I just don't
apply. I think when I get back,
if I actually start trying and drilling
and actually practicing and getting that
extra workout in, I could cut it up
and sure enough, that's what happened.
So what was the first step?
When I came back, it was weird.
At first run I was living at,
my dad's shop is probably 200 yards from
my house and it was raining and that's
all I, that's one reason why
I ran, because I didn't want
to get away. I was like,
I'm about to run through the house. And
I'm thinking like, but here's the thing,
I don't know if I can make, and they're
right in that doubt in my mind, like,
why are you telling some of you? Can
you make it? How many from the injuries?
What broke it in what January or December.
And this was summertime, so it was a lot
like I had the cast on for like five,
six months. So yeah, I went to Arab. Ooh.
It was like, it was five, six months.
It was bad. And then I, right now I've
got the plate and the screws in the end,
but I broke some of the screws because
I was like trying to move in a wrestling
stance in my boot and I slipped.
My Dad had to tile or just submit and
he had a little gloss over it and I was
washing the cars one day and then I was
like, oh, just going to and my shadows to,
I don't know what, I slipped on a
wet spot and I slipped. I felt it.
And the two are the pins that
go across my ankle, his snap.
So I had to wait for all that
to heal again. Jesus Christ.
It was a whole process.
So I was late snap the two.
I still got the two long screw that they
take out the leave to seven and go up
the femur or the Tibia. But the too
long was it supposed to pull out,
but the middle and I slit,
they've broken half of my bones so that
made the bone heal slower cause now it
was just a little spot
they drilled through.
It opened up like that
much that much more.
So he had to wait for all that to
heal before I could actually walk.
They take the screws out and
putting new ones in there.
So you got broken screws in your,
and if you look at like when I work
out I got my barrio ankles fat as hell.
That's because of the plate, the plate
and the screws. The screws are so long.
The ankle bone, the swelling and
there's different, exactly the angle.
Which ankle?
That's a fat ankle
and that's the normal was pretty fat too.
Oh,
oh yeah. Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
That's a big difference. Yeah.
I get done this one.
It's like this big cause all the blood,
everything's swollen around the screw.
Wow. So does it fuck with you anymore?
Like when it gets cold out or
anything like, yeah, mental,
everything has mentioned to
me now everything in life,
even when she hates it because I tell
her all the time she had a negative uh,
Nigga insight on something.
Like find the positive in it.
Like it's all in your mind.
You can make the best of anything.
And I mean this isn't this happening.
Like what are,
you could be dead or
you good with no legs.
Like she got her car smashed that work.
Somebody hit the side of a tour,
it all up and had to go in
the shot and he was like, Hey,
the windows didn't break.
Those like thinking about it
drives and your windows ain't Bro.
It's the middle of winter. They ain't
gotta be cold. It can get hurt. Yeah.
It's like a million different
things you can find to be sad,
but find the good thing
is to find the positive.
It's going to get fixed eventually.
So this ankle fucks with you still,
but not enough to stop you.
I'm nothing to stop me and you,
but does it affect you at all when
you kick things? Depends. Yeah,
they digging like if I can,
if they go to do the elbow,
like I go to kick the liver and you go
to sit on it and like the elbow kind of
catch it. I feel it. But again,
it doesn't stop me. Right. Lasts
15 minutes. That's nothing last. So
my last so long I'm a bouncer sound.
Keep going. Yeah. So you
get out of the injury,
you have the cast on you
for five or six months,
you realize how blessed you were to be
able to move around and that feeling once
you get your your leg back under
you and start moving again,
what is the changes you make?
How do you start to move your
life in this positive way? Well,
after I made that first job and I
realized I'm, I'm good like at first,
not of myself, but I made it because I
told myself I can do it. I made it here.
There's no injuries. I'm fine. I
thought it was just slow and steady.
Just start hand fighting like good the
little you've got to take down dummies a
hang on the wall, there's go down and
move, you know, not nothing fashion.
It's work hand fighting.
Just kinda grabbed her leg,
working on my shots in and out,
in and out in the morning before practice
and I used to go wash the gospel off
season, practice study and then
when I came back it was just,
Oh I have to heavyweight coach
that coached and we drill today.
You asked me to Julie. Yeah, coach
could see it. I just want to work for,
I'm going to do a little bit extra
stuff. Natural practice, work with me,
then the other coach or come work with me.
It got to the point where like in the
morning I was in there before school and I
was there after school for practice.
Now stay afterward, coaching drills,
different stuff.
They must have been so confused and they
didn't like the coach says night and
day like they weren't doing.
Now is night and day.
Tell us what's so strange.
You got this lazy kid and all
of a sudden he becomes a savage.
They haven't, when I go back
to the school and I'm visit,
they always asked me to come talk to these
people. They call me a success story.
Not only was this, but I grew up in
an area where there was no black.
I was the only black family there,
so we had racism my whole life.
You know what I mean? Dealing
with that. So that's another man.
That was the mental, the mental,
the mental fucks of it all.
Like no matter what I did,
you're going to be wrong.
Like I was another core Anderson to that
was even worse and he was actually a
troublemaker.
So when he would get in trouble,
they would always come get me out of the
classroom like it was Cory and I will
get put on it. I ain't even did it. I
was a good kid, never did nothing wrong.
But I'm not an officer principal
walking like wrong core. I'm like,
of course it's the wrong course.
Every time I remember Corey,
Richard Anderson and Corey see Anderson,
I'm Corey. See he's Cory Richard,
but they always pulled me in
there and it was just cause I was,
it was only a few of us in my high school
in the fact that I never did drugs.
She was like,
when we was on the ring I said I don't
wanna I wanna come in and show him shoot
with you. I don't want to smoke weed. I
never did drugs. I don't do none of that.
I've been a good kid but to deal with
that stuff I used to get pulled over for
no reason. I had a nice truck. Stn
drops the ground rims and speakers.
I used to get pulled over and then my
friends get put in cuffs and sit on the
curb when they searched the car looking
for something when I went to college is
the same thing.
Get pulled over all the time and teach
you and be like every time you late for
class you said you got to put off.
Like I was telling him on the way here,
like I'm serious. I have classmates that
saw, I'm like no, he's telling the truth.
Miss Starks,
we saw them on the side of the road,
like he always gets pulled over cause
it's nice vehicle black and they always
thinking of some,
I know that's just where I'm from.
So dealing with that and the mentality,
I finally figured out, like I said,
that's why when people doubt me,
I think trying to prove wrong,
because I had coaches in high school,
I won't put names on air,
but I remember even when I was doing good,
I knew I was doing good because I had led
team a sex. I didn't start,
you know what I mean?
I lay the the starting lineman out or
beat this guy and this and that and this
and that and I never got the
position or something was around it.
And then when I came back after I made
you a sickle, he, oh, I remember this.
Like I ain't trying to hear that and
I'm only coaching at high school.
I will say that that believed him.
It was a wrestling coach, Marty,
because Marty Causa made
everything possible to make,
let me meet Dave Clem, who was my
junior college coach who led me to Russ.
Dave Grimm led me to been asked her who?
Tim fader and everything and I've been
blessed with the people in my life to
bring me to Frankie and mark and Ricardo
and I got like the awesome and people
around me like my mom says,
you've always been blessed to have a
good circle of people and the one year I
had a bad coach in college and it's like
my mom said we didn't have so much good.
Don't let this one coach to Fiji now
I'll never forget him. Jason Valley,
I'll put his name on air.
That guy at that made me the toughest
man I could because no matter what I did,
he wanted to make sure he could break him.
He had control over me.
I was 16 I was away from home and
South Carolina, no family, no money.
He having it on a full ride and he
was just used that I got you here.
You here because of me. You do this or
I'm going to cut you cut meat in. Fuck it.
Come, hi. Y'All seen I go get recruited
and he put him back on the scene.
You still an ally, you can't do that.
This is new. So it's kind of like,
I think that's where I got the mentality
where I want to prove people wrong
because I beat the starter
and I beat him bad.
1301 toilet and every rests are beating
them. But you still not started.
What the fuck you make them run them off
for? Like I didn't beat him every time.
When you lost on the first dual in a
match by riding time the first week of
school, not beat him every time. But
you're not gonna let me start. Nope.
Cause he pins people and you only get
points kind of like finally he knocks
people out and you only win by decision
and that's kind of like, all right.
So I left, went to Whitewater where
I met Ben and everything else again.
Went there,
they coach knew who I was.
Nobody else knew who I was cause I didn't
get the rest of the year before I was
a bench warmer. The kid on the team but
never wrestled. That's so crazy. Killed.
Never asked.
My parents would drive 16 hours of watch
me duel and he'd make me sit in the
bench the whole term. It'd be
a tournament. He'll be like,
you're not rustling today. My parents
were here like, you're not wrestling.
They're like,
my friends drove six.
You're not wrestling like you got
me eight hours from the school.
My parents drove all yet this
guy's problem. We don't know.
But I got teammates now and God is still
that fighting everything and they're
like, Bro, you got out of there and
like a lot of guys, he had them.
They're academically,
he like all we're going to short term
short credits you blisters and that you're
gonna do half credits.
You're going to be at a restaurant.
So he was just sitting at the heck to
a loss of dis. He just wanted to win.
That was it. So like guys are
finished wrestling career.
They didn't have the courtesy.
Gradually like, coach, I need help.
Like what can I do? You don't wrestle
for me no more. I was like, Bro,
I'm only here because of you.
But I left and he was our,
he kept hitting me up like, oh,
you keep coming back next year.
I let you start next year. If you
beat him again, fuck. And I was like,
exactly what? I said, I want you to Aad
office. Told them what was going on.
They gave me my letters and trends.
Let me transfer out,
but I couldn't go division two like you
can leave but you can't go division two
he can't hold you back. And
we're like, that's fine. I'm out.
I left like a before school and he
showed up at my house one day. You're
like, where are you? I'm at your house.
Like I'm gone bro. And what do you mean
I'm going like I'm done. I'm transferring.
Like you can't ask them the papers.
How did you get that?
Like I went behind your back.
I got it done.
I'm out of here and then Tim
Fader to coach a whitewater.
I remember he put them at my house.
I almost didn't go back to school cause
he kinda got in my head like I don't
want to go nowhere else and waste my
last year of school doing the same shit.
I can't trust anybody there. I took
what, 60 years before an injury,
but I was beating everybody,
you know,
I mean lots of d one d two guys and so
it was like I don't want to go anywhere
else and somebody's gonna
screw me over for ride.
But then this guy pulled up my driveway
when I was working one day. He's like,
I'm looking for Corey Anderson.
I've seen him before,
but I didn't really know much about
him and we went to lunch or whatever.
He was like,
I know your story,
but thing is I can't give you a full
ride because the d three we can't give
money. I want you to wrestle for me,
this, this and this. And like I said,
when I went d three, nobody knew who
I was because I didn't get to wrestle,
but he knew like, we're not even
gonna let you rest for a while.
So I thought the right off the get go.
Like what was the same shit?
Like what the fuck?
He's like,
no it ain't that cause I don't
want people to know what we got.
We're going to wait till the first home
duel and I'm going to let you loose in
the first home, drive the number
three dude in the country.
And I never forget that way cause
it's you ready? Like what's your mean?
Like it's the time you get to come out.
Gave him my thing,
like you ready to show out?
Like you know, I'm ready dog,
the number three guy out by
like 12 points and he's like,
who the fuck is this kid? I was
like, yes. I'm finally home.
And then shortly after I met Russ Davey,
a guy who came from Colorado
who coached in Wisconsin.
He was my heavyweight coach, Olympic
guy. And then uh, he brought in,
been asking is how I got in a fight in
the bin. It was just like, like I said,
the people around you,
he's just Mosey like I'm
blessed I'm saying or thinking
about it and it makes me
feel good cause all the things I've
been through and everything and it all
worked out. Yeah. The reason I haven't
lesson Dick Coach probably it helped,
it helped me. It wasn't about, and
my coach told me when I signed,
when I signed like,
cause it gave me a it as the one that
kept saying they give me a full ride.
He kept saying court,
it ain't all about the money.
Like it's the most of the Sydney and live.
It's not about the money coach Clem and
Steven Rally and they both said like
it's not about the money corp remember,
remembers most of the most
important decision of your
life. Don't let the money.
Few. But that was, that's what
it was for me. I'm a, you know,
I went to the school as a walk home pretty
much now I'm getting full offers from
everywhere and I'm going
to a number one school,
division two and they give me a full ride.
Like I thought that was something when
I got there I figured out what he meant
and I'll never forget calling both coach
like you guys are right and I'm back
home now let's try to figure
out what's now we can go in AI.
I know a few schools that
won't get as good coaches,
Blah Blah Blah and I'm just going
to chill and think about it.
When that coach Kane in the fact that
he came to my house, reached out to him,
he told me, I can't give you money but
I want you for you and as a leader.
And I first got there even though he
told me he wasn't gonna let me wrestle.
He let me run practices for like the
first month because he couldn't teach it
before season. Got Things like I
want you to like run practice this,
this and this. Cause you
got that mentality. You can
help these guys show us.
You did in d two number one school.
You can show us stuff here. You know,
I ended up being the first NCAA all
American or instead of like finals the
school had in 22 years,
you know,
I lead a team and take downs all the way
up until like the regional tournament.
My roommate,
when we had a competition going on,
I did a lot of things that most
people didn't see heavyweights do.
The way I shot, the way our wrestling,
my mentality, I was always working.
I was going to do a strength
and conditioning before
practice and before the
morning,
like six o'clock we asked you in the
conditioning and I've got a class at one
and I'd be in the gym lifting.
I don't start the training till three
and it went from just me to me and my
teammate.
Oh,
me and my roommate to other teammates
and like is that people will see how
you're doing it. And they were
jumping in and before you know,
it was like six or seven
of us working out. Yeah.
And we just motivate each other.
And the bond. We had her as a team,
like I remember getting it and everybody's
like, oh what's our goal on the,
I thought about was national,
we want to win nationals or win conference
look like what the Fuck Y'all talking
about conference?
I was like the first step you got
conference regionals all is national.
What about the big picture? Like oh
we would never one conference before.
Like we should still want to get
nationals and like by the end of the year
everybody was feeding off each other.
We had,
we had three guys from the same high
school meet a 97 89 or 87 or 84 pounds,
excuse me.
And they call it as a high nigga death
row cause I was at school and like death
row sugar night and all of that.
So one got prayed up shirts and
it was us three and it was like,
it was so cool to have three guys
that was from the same school.
We grew up right down the street from
each other but we all went separate ways.
One went here, one went there, we
ended up in junior college together.
We and the one guy at our very last year,
we all ended up together as a
team captains, senior years.
I last time to do it together to Hoo Rah.
We brought like our whole high school
would come to all our matches and there's
only like an hour from home.
It was just cool man.
And I was like I said when I met Ben there
and he brought me to this thing and I
didn't want to fight again. I
was, I had a doubt in my mind
go to that, but I want to go back
to your high, your high school days.
When you made that big shift, did
you slip at all like you, you,
you went from being a guy who was kind
of lazy and unmotivated to a guy who is
very disciplined that it
was like night and day,
but was there ever a time where
you fell back to your old ways?
I mean it was,
sounds like it took a lot of motivation
in pep talk to myself to get out and do
something every time like I
wanted to instead of go work out,
go play video games.
All was big in a dirt bike and a four
wheeler and like when I get off the bus,
you can hear the dirt
bikes coming to my house.
I had the motocross track and my bag up.
Me and the neighbor,
he had a freestyle track,
got dirt bike track and I'd get off
the bus and be thinking like, God,
I'm about to go do my homework and
had to go do a little workout lift or
something and you hear him come and it's
like, oh, I want to go ride and stay.
I want to go ride. But at the same time
like you're a restaurant, you're arrested.
I forgot the two. Which
one is first? You know,
I let the guys go ride and my track
and I do pushups or whatever and do my
homework, whatever it was had
to do just a little something.
I'm almost like get something am I did
a little bit something that's more than
the next person.
You know,
by the time my senior year came around
and it was Kinda like I still wasn't
all of them,
but I was a little more,
I didn't get it all in until after
that second injury in college.
I just drink college was the same injury,
same, less same leg, different engines.
What? What'd you do this time?
I snapped my leg and through.
How'd he got this? Til this
day I, I just remember hearing,
was it wrestling, wrestling? Me and my
coach drilling very slow, very slow.
June,
but we had brand new.
Max said it was super sticky and I
have a brand new wrestling shoes,
which were super sticky and I remember
that you're a coach Morgan high.
So we're going to work to the chain
restaurant. I shoot a single day.
You get the single back when I shoot
a doe. But you bumped with the hip.
She snapped to your shot. He grabbed
a single day. I snapped the foot down.
He shot dope. When I hit him with my
hips, I fell backwards and hear a pop,
but I didn't feel it and he stood over.
I remember him standing on a few of us,
both sides like, don't
look down. Don't look down.
Now of course I'm gonna tell you, don't
look, you're going to look. I look at my,
what was like point like
this and it was down. Ah,
I turn it off as an armored car.
We got a pool on the other side of the
door and I'm trying to get to doing this,
John Myself and paint out a painkiller.
I can't have tool and DP.
I'm trying to draw, but like it
hurt. Like I was like, I want to die.
So I'm just going.
I remember him pulling me over and try
to go through your mind when shock.
It was shock. You don't think that's a
crazy thing. If you don't want to go drag,
it hurts you snapchat. No, no, no.
Not One spot.
Three spots.
So it was like shooting up your whole
legs and your back. It was like, oh,
I just wanted just, oh. It's like I'm
just going go jump in the water. Wow.
First thing my mind goes,
bear called falling water.
I wasn't the most sane kid but that was
the most certain first they on my mind
go find the water.
Just just ended in and they flipped me
over and I remember they threw it up on a
punching bag to do with the old injury.
Nothing good though.
It's completed are totally different.
I like four or five inches up from no
injuries. Snapped freak accidents. What?
I kept saying hospital, it's a freak
accident. What did they do then?
Go to the hospital that day and they
snap him to guide us, snatches it back,
pulls her in,
smashing lines,
all the bones up and they put like
we're putting the cast from now,
but you got to get plates and
pins to sit the street and that.
When I was out for,
again,
I was October 27 and I came back after
at least back January 13 to 14 it was
like a little bit before regional and
we didn't have a heavyweight all year
because I got hurt and you know the
guys got kicked out of school, whatever.
So three months ish. Yeah, he'll fat.
I wasn't back but I was cleared to start
drilling and we're begging the coach
like coach,
just let me come back.
I can say it was six points because every
time when went got on the rest of this
automatic six did they have to put plates
in your Shin on on side of my late,
you're gonna play it.
You can feel it if you bring your hand up.
Donald's like all bent up and from now
all the wars and shit kicks in. Wrestling.
It's like all wobbly holds all
kinds of stuff from getting kicked,
getting kicked in it from wrestling.
People do foot sweeps.
You ever get to look at an x ray
of it to see what it looks like?
I have an extra forever. I should see
what it looks like pretty bad by now.
I remember my first term it when
somebody's foot swept me. Oh my goodness.
That feeling like God having an under
hook and he kicked that plate and I just
felt like it didn't kick my feet.
I just fail because it's the first
time you feel it in that pain ship up.
You've never felt it right.
Your nerves run up down there.
So when it hit and everything just shut
and I fell and he pay me. I was like,
it was like, what's wrong? I'm like, Yo,
my leg gave him, I'm still on the mat.
Like I don't know what the fuck
happened there. Like your nerves.
It try and sound like you got nerves on
the side of the leg. You're at the plate.
We did probably kicked it.
He hit the plate and another
thing you had to get in my mind,
I said like this is going to happen often.
You just got a bit of a tough ended up
and just go through. Yeah. You have a,
an extra vulnerable spot now. Yeah. Yeah.
And have you been low leg
kick there a lot. Yeah,
he did it like four times low Lakey.
It's just like I said,
I got to a point now I just deal with it.
That was in 2007 this is 2019
it's 12 years of dealing with it.
You get to a point where it's kind of
like, it's not really a pain anymore.
It's just a just a pesky injury.
You can feel it,
but some of those injuries they'll go in
after it's healed up and take the plate
out. They say they can
do that, but to do that,
because I got the broken pins
cause those pens are broke.
They got cut like a whole section
on my leg. What do you mean?
I'd be out of commission for a long
time and I was like, I'm used to it now.
Is there any benefit if they do that?
I get my whole leg back.
I grabbed my leg, but that's the only
benefit. Like I said, I said I can train,
right? Yeah. Like this is going to bother.
He's like, I deal with it when I retired,
we do all of that, but right
now there's no problem. Wow.
So you have this shift in high school,
you,
you'll make it to senior year and
you're a different person night and day,
but you're still not the Corey Anderson
of today. So the second injury,
what is the second injury do for you when
you snapped it and the second injury?
That was just,
I mean that just because I
didn't get to show what I can do.
It motivated me that much more that
when I come back I gotta be undeniable.
I got to show,
I got to do like nobody knows what I can
do because I didn't make it to state my
senior year in high school. But then
we went to team state and I pinned it,
got it took fourth in state.
So I knew I could do it by
just saying make it there.
So when I got hurt my freshman
freshman year, I was gone.
That was the year I was going to show
people Koreans and which are used to know
what you think this,
this and this.
Then I got hurt and it kind of set me
back and I was just in my mind I was very,
I was sad. Like I remember being
at home. I was emotionally sad,
but when I went to go back and
I couldn't focus on wrestling,
I just put my mind on schoolwork and
that's when I figured out I can do
schoolwork. I finished my freshman year
with a 3.25 GPA. After missing like three,
four months, I had to make up everything
and take tests and that's not real.
I was like, I can do that
too, so that was more thing.
I got the thing I got out of that injury.
Not so much the athletic part.
I was more motivated to
work even harder next year,
but I found the fact that I can do
schoolwork if I want you. Again,
it's just a mental thing. I have to
take the time to study. I've never,
I had never studied before
that ever then do any homework.
It was our boss on by his homework or
take somebody knows and trying to fill in
answers just to get something to say.
It was a completion credit,
but when I had had nothing to do, I
couldn't wrestle. I couldn't, you know,
I couldn't run, I couldn't
go play basketball in the
back, but everybody else,
it was the only back and focus on
our school at the time I came back,
my GPA like two point
something because I hadn't
been in class for so long,
so I had to get audit up a it before the
end of the year and finished with a 3.0
at least not finished with
a 3.25 for that was my,
to make academic all American was my,
that was my highlight in my freshman year.
I didn't get the rest of all American,
but I had the academic, all American.
That's something I can work on
because as a kid, my parents,
she's my mom and eighth grade bet me $100
I wouldn't graduate my own mother and
she's my mom. My biggest motivation
for myself before my son came here,
my mother was the hand that
pushed me over everything.
She's always my dad
comes to the work ethic.
My mom was always make sure you do things
right, you can do this, this and this.
I always helped me.
I struggle with reading.
She's helped me learn how to read faster,
read better and do things to the best
of my ability and academic roar because
sports and hard work is going to beat her.
But education some you can always fall
back on so but how has your so bad?
I used to and I lived next door,
so the middle school selves back to eighth
grade year they opened a new high or
middle school up the street from my house.
So I would mess up from school.
I don't do homework. I don't know
why. I think I would get away with it.
I'm getting to class.
My mom sit in the principal's office
because it was going for a walk for it.
They call it according to his
homework again cause she was on it.
She would call like of course
messed up in school, call me.
She had me in summer camp.
I had to go to summer school one year
when I pass all my classes because she
wanted me to get that fact like just
cause you pass, they let you pass.
I mean you did good, you passed, but you
got to learn how to work. You're going to.
But that was another thing.
I didn't have the mentality that my
mom wanted me to have when it come to
working for academics and stuff.
So what made you do that? What,
what was the shift that caused that
from the, the injury? The second set,
one second I had that us to focus on,
it was either that or become a
bum at the school of cinema room,
skipping class and fell out.
So I had to get my grades up if I
wanted the rest of the next year.
So it probably been something
that was bothering you already.
They didn't bother me.
I didn't care about my grades because I
was athletic doing athletics and the way,
it's kind of like the movies have you
competing and they know you're good,
your assets to a team, the teachers help
you. They tried it, they don't give you,
but they'll help you out take
you got questions, ask questions.
They won't fail you.
You know if I they can do everything
they can to make sure I learn.
So when you realizing because the
injury that maybe your athletic career
wouldn't be there and you needed,
you needed to get this education,
fight it cause not, didn't have the help
I had in class when I was an athlete.
They help you a little bit more but not,
I'm not wrestling.
It's kind of like my GPA doesn't matter
for the team anymore and I haven't
missed it from school for so long.
When I came back,
it's kind of like now I got a lot to
make up for has got to do it on my own.
I was studying,
that's all I had class and my dorm room
class or Dorma from that point on from
that injury then you would you get your
academic work in order and you start
being disciplined in all our areas of
your life and you feel like that carried
over every Catholics as where
everything works together.
Everything works for one thing
that's come out of that. Okay.
Like first thing we learned orientation,
the college coach comes to,
we going around room like guys,
we got your athletic scholarship but
you're here as a student athlete and I
remember back and coaching at the
same college and him giving the same
speech and the right on the board.
Student athlete, we gonna make it
in two parts. First part student,
second part athlete so that we don't write
it on the board. What does this mean?
So first priority school
after that next priority,
athletics to me.
After that you got your family,
then it's making sure you stay out
of trouble and that the last thing,
the very most important thing and to
come to college, it's just social life.
The rest of that.
Everything else comes first and at the
end then you were a bunch of friends and
trying to be cool and all the extra stuff.
You know,
I'm 17 when I went to college, I
graduated high school at 17. So I'm young,
I'm not even an adult, but in my mind, I'm
on my own, I'm doing what I want, blah,
blah, blah. I'm showing I'm
being an ass, you know? Right.
Not like getting in trouble but not
paying attention in school and not worry
about chorus doing part. I'm just
an athlete. They're not gonna find,
ask questions, act like I'm struggling
and they tried to help me out, you know.
But I know they're not going to give
me an f because, um, I'm trying,
but I really wasn't.
I'm asking questions.
I'm sitting in front of class so
you're not going to give me an f,
but they're going to make sure I
don't, I'm eligible. The rest of it,
I'm not going to fail. Right.
So when you get Angela,
you realize that ain't there no more
cause she ain't got none the rest of for
you all school now.
So now you got to you,
you can't say I got practice so I can't,
I can't stay was not a
big eye opener for you.
When you realize that you
can do good at school too.
That's 100% because in your
whole life when you didn't try,
you didn't care and it had that no child
left behind pretty much before they
made the official thing.
It was always there.
Cause I know I didn't do enough in school
but somehow I graduated every year.
Somehow I graduated.
Cause there's always one teacher,
one person I looked out for me,
I guess I've been blessed to
have that in middle school.
Was Ms for met to this day. We still
talk, I go home, we have lunch, breakfast,
whatever will.
Yes.
If it wasn't for her I probably would
have dropped out of high school.
That's cool. Yeah. That's very cool.
So so in college now you're athletic
careers in order, you're, you're,
you're getting your schoolwork in.
What was it that made you even
consider being an MMA fighter?
Been asked her funky ban on Cuban and
I didn't even consider he tricked me
because I went,
you're kidding me all through.
Cause I had teammates that date MMA,
they all rest but when it's over they
all the amateur MMA fights of course he
should try it like your
movement and stuff.
You're so light on your feet and
fast as your weight. You can kill it.
I got a metal plate in my leg bro.
I had tore my shoulder and I got
some areas I wouldn't be good.
I'd be laid up too much. I didn't like
what you think this isn't. This denied,
denied. Denied. My senior year,
fifth year senior being comes up,
he started working with me and Ben was
like one of my main restaurant partners
and kind of like you said Lemon Chieko
like you got somebody you go to punch.
He's not there because the same way on
wrestling and I used to try to pick his
brain and how do you do this?
Like I'd be dead to right on a double leg.
Pick you up in the air.
I go to take you on and I land on my
face and you're nowhere to be found.
You on my back. And how does that happen?
That's why they call me the fuck man.
I'm the king of the funk. I same here.
Come and praxis Sanders, kick it off,
put his shoes on.
He just looked like a floppy guy.
Like how his guy dinner thing about him.
He doesn't look physically person.
This is being like, no, I'm
about to blow through this.
Do hidden where Aa gone every time.
High Christ gone. I took him down,
I think one time my college career clean
take down and then it's just like what
the, and after college I was like,
I want to do the Olympics Bro.
And you've been there, but I don't
know any freestyle rules. Oh,
we can work together.
Whenever him and my coach both wrestle
at the Olympic level working together and
then one day send me, I just like,
oh, I'm not making it here today,
but meet me here at this address. And we
will work, blah blah, blah. Bring a year.
I get up there and Rufus sport,
but outside of a bank it's still like,
is there any for bank downstairs?
Yeah, because I'm looking like,
what don't fuck is, where
am I going? I texted like,
oh it goes to the science down and says
you're going to see a sign roof for
sport, this and this. And I walked
down the stairs like what is,
he must have Matt senior's home
and I go in there and you got UFC,
they're doing a Anthony pay
this doing a jump off kicked,
making some photo for
the magazine or whatever.
And he got like Pascal [inaudible] and
Sergio page. You've got Ben Asheron.
It was a few other Eric Koch, other
UFC guys. And I'm looking like,
what is going on?
He always asked hidden pads and when
my practice and being around the Kate,
Oh hey, cool, I'm glad
you could make this.
Isn't this I say no wrestling gym
when he says, he's like, oh yeah,
well I want to talk to you about
that. We're to a new sport. What,
what? Yes. Like, I mean, I know I heard
you say you didn't want to fight whatever,
bro. I think you could be good. I
just want you to try. If you don't,
if you don't like it after you try it,
we'd go back to wrestling, blah blah blah,
this and this. I'm like, alright.
And I go to the front desk and
the lady I met at the front desk,
they introduced me. It was my wife. Now
they didn't know Jamie. She's in my desk.
So I get the gear to give me some gloves
and whatever and I was like, you know,
I really don't want to do the training,
the ice on the side and watch.
I hit the bag a little bit.
I'm just watching and at the time,
this is where my mind was already set.
You got an opportunity, you got to try it.
But I didn't try it the day I remember
driving home. It's hour and a half dry.
Hold your, I'm at myself like you a bitch
talking about selling you a bitch. Boy.
You didn't do that yet. Arbitrary.
You ain't even take it. You a bitch.
I can't believe you didn't do that.
So I get home, I tell Ben like,
I'm sorry I didn't try but I
like to do it again. Like whoa,
it was good cause tomorrow
morning 9:00 AM we up there.
I get up early seven 35 and motorcycle
up shoot all the way up to Milwaukee.
I get their roof, Duke roof
element. Oh Cory, nice to
meet you. I heard about this,
this, this like I can't, yes sir. I
didn't do it but I want to try it today.
I just was like, well that's good.
I'm glad you came. Like why is that?
Like Sticks Barn Day
testing. I did amateur boxing.
They got when I broke my leg,
yeah I did like boxing in the gym for
Rehab because my brother in law was
oppression of box at the time and
I had two amateur fights and uh,
so I had that and I came home,
my gloves and everything but old ratty
title gloves falling apart and like all I
got is my gloves and my shorts. I go,
well we got gear would get you stuff.
Hey gear and Shin pads.
This isn't this.
They gave me too obviously combat
corner Shim pass almost like a youth and
wasn't extra loss on one coach,
my knee and one cover like half machine
and like there's old raggedy headgear
and they got them all. He's like,
yeah man, it's all you need.
And so we're going to spa. So my time
I go with being so being, you know,
taking it easy on me. Boom, boom. He shoot
on me. I defended in MMA is different.
I can sprawl out hard.
I well there you go.
Now I'm gonna put you or somebody else.
Of course Anthony Pettis,
he's too small like, well you need to do
and feel like to get kicked. What bow?
I just kept kicking my leg
and I, Greg, what do you do?
Like I'm arrested is I take them down.
I took him no lie. You do big family.
You're going to hurt him. And they
put me with a heavyweight. He said,
now I want just to take
everything you did.
You was punching being
and you took him down.
It took nine Anthony to do everything.
We just got your size and I fucking just
hit him with a bunch of Jab crosses,
blast double on a punch.
It's like just got,
they ain't no grind but just hitting
like dog and stand up and do it again.
I did get us kept doing it, doing it,
doing it and it was over here like I act.
There you go.
Your first process is not the way,
and I hate to tell the court heard you
kept saying you're not a fighter but you
are an MMA fighter and I can tell you
right now, but working with a lot of guys,
you could be in the UFC in three
fights. Yeah, right. Whatever.
I don't think like I'm dead
serious and three fights.
So what you got and your mentality
from what I've seen in wrestling,
if you put into this, you could be
in UFC in three fights, whatever,
but I liked that. I liked the training
and I kept coming back and I never rested.
This was 2012 right after college.
That's not that long ago,
man.
Oh my first day of 2013 top level MMA
fighter in one of the most talent rich
divisions in the light
heavyweight division.
And you've only been
doing it for seven years.
I was in the UFC was seven
months after my first bike,
seven months and I was in
the top team within a year.
So I'm learning. I didn't have an
amateur career. I had three fights,
ultimate fighter one that top 10 and
I was at a year of all MMA training.
That's it.
Saw people keep talking to shit,
but I'm like, they don't understand.
I did this like most of these guys,
I look at pictures of guys
I've been training with.
I got guys at the gym now that's still
amateurs. They pose a throwback Thursday,
my senior year in college,
I have a throwback picture.
It'd be me and college in 2007 it'd be
different like the third or fourth MMA
fight.
It's like, and he's got to still
amateur. And how old are you now?
I'm 29 did you still not even
really in your prime. You know what?
It was like 31 32 back. I said,
I'm coming in. I'm learning now.
You are learning now,
but that's crazy that you were in a
top 10 a year in the MMA training.
They'll just,
cause we always cite Francis in Ghana,
the Francis and gone was one
of the craziest stories ever.
That guy goes from no MMA training at
all to five years later fighting for the
title you know at like,
but he's,
what you did is as impressive the fact
that you hit top 10 with a year of MMA
training and that's bananas man.
Even in the tough house,
I remember the guy was like,
you could hear him in the
kitchen with all talking about,
oh what's your background in business?
I went on a tough with with
four or five months experience,
have my three fights back to back to the
bay and I remember my coach is pushing
it. That third fight we can get just
terrified. Why are you pushing so hard?
And then when it was over and was like,
oh hi,
this is why we had to get that
last fight off my fighter trials.
The next Tuesday in Indiana.
You're going fuck outta here.
I gotta work this and I'm going over and
they called me Monday night like, Yo,
you're doing like I'm at work.
I work night shift,
hung off to one and when
he'd off Mimi and Maha
site, what? We're going to Indiana like,
I'm not going to get to USC and I'm going
to do it. I'm going to go to Holloway.
Oh, all right. I see your mouse hung up
the phone. I get off, I go and I was like,
Bro, what the fuck you talking about?
He jumped in drivers. He's like, Gideon,
like what are you talking about? So you
were saying you want, if you get in,
you want to go the hard like
getting earned from doing
the ultimate fight. Yeah.
I wanted to like get enough fights
and then somebody see me, he's like,
oh here's your take a short
notice fight or whatever.
It was a fantastic opportunity
for exposure and exactly.
But in my mind I had just started three,
four months.
I'm thinking like I'm just beating up
cans. I don't think I'm ready yet. Right.
But they say like court,
we see you man like you,
you have the opportunity to beat
these guys. Like you beating this guy.
He's been training forever. He's
been pro, he's been dilatory doesn't.
Jacoby was my first sparring
partner and I went to Illinois.
He had been in the UFC now and that was
one of my first and I was taking him
down and ground and pound but striking.
I didn't have that.
But if I can do is use your takedowns man,
you taking everybody out and you're
doing good. Use that. And when I left,
when I went there and whatever, my
coach was like, just go do what you do.
I have no doubt they're going to pick you.
But the reason they picked
me wasn't the same. You know,
they picked me thinking it was going
to be an easy fight for whoever,
but it's backfired on me because my
work ethic, they didn't know me. Right.
You know,
I was cracking jokes like I can beat
anybody you having and they was laughing.
I'm going to be laughing at my jokes. Come
to find out, they told him at the end,
one guy told me like, you know, when we
picture, we didn't think you could win.
I go after [inaudible] we
picked her because we thought
she was going to lose it.
Kelly and nuts and get him an easy fight
in and I'll look. It kind of backfired.
And it was like,
cause they didn't know who I was.
They didn't know him as a person.
And I name drop man, he used.
And I think that was the
only reason why I got there.
Like I trained with Matt Hughes here and
there, Blah Blah. You know Maddie, Oh man,
he's our guy.
Oh can you make it to Vegas next week?
I think I can make it yesterday.
If he would have told me and I go
pack your bags, you're going wow.
And that was it. But you, the thing is,
even though you were a year and you
were so many years into wrestling,
and I think to this day that wrestling
is the most important skill in MMA
because you get to dictate
where the fight takes place.
The superior wrestler gets to dis,
every fight starts standing up and
you have to know how to strike.
But a superior wrestler gets to
dictate where the fights take place.
And you see that with guys like Khabib,
he see that with so many
superior grapplers when
they get ahold of a guy it's
their dominance is one of the most
important aspects of fighting.
So you did have all that but that's,
I have the strike,
the basic striking and wrestling. But like
I said, when I came to meet Mark Henry,
Ricardo,
Amada,
like that's what took me until two years
into your chat with him in two years.
I was a year in like three months and I
guess that's why I didn't have anything.
And Mark Tell people all the time,
like when you hear him say it,
I am telling people all the time when
you guys want to see like hard working
with habit core, my core,
it is a purifier of what I,
what I'm coaching because he came here
with nothing and like you get guys that
come in and like Lance Palmer,
now he's been fight him.
So he's wanting to Pfl you've got all
these guys have been fighting 10 12 years
before they meet mark.
So it's kind of like they just tuning up.
So anything when you got a guy like
me to has nothing. The Gym I was at,
we literally like,
I'll that roof for sport for a little bit,
but I got to college coaching
job and had the, so I met a group of
guys to mark [inaudible] at the time,
but he ended up leaving to go to overseas
and it was probably six of us and we
had a fight.
A guy who owned the warehouse like,
Oh you can put Madison here and just
in the corner. You guys can just train.
We didn't have to just be practice
whenever has striking practice,
no tie practice. We really showed up
ground and pound. It would make gloves.
We Punch each other in the face.
Why I get out sparring? No,
Bridget hasn't spawned. I mean you
got injured. We don't want to hear it.
Just beat the shit out of each
other until it's over. There was,
it was a horrible one at a time.
No heat.
We had a little bit about this big on
the corner mat and we, we in Illinois,
central Illinois,
it's freezing negative twin.
We end up fucking dudes bring
and hit the hand, hit the back,
freeze and break their hand.
We don't have any insurance,
US beating the shit out of each other,
but we got the opportunity for one of us,
it was three 12 hours,
but I was the only one that they was
gonna let to go shut off from a fighter.
I had the least amount of fights,
but there you're the only one that could
actually work and make us look good on
there. So you get on the ultimate
fighter and you meet Mark Henry.
You want to win and then you go from
there. You Go and move to New Jersey.
Is that what you do? I went home. I had
met Ali on the show. You know what I mean?
Ali was there every day.
He even said like pro wrestling this car.
Like how are you good at wrestling?
Hanzo came on,
he said like you're wrestling
is key. That's when everybody
letting me know, mark,
first thing he says, you're wrestling.
They made it known like rustling,
it's going to run this and uh, and then
at least they're right. Then he was like,
I'll work with you and the union had
to me as a manager, but I help you,
like I help lead you in the
right way what you need.
Because I didn't have
anybody to direct me.
I knew nothing been asking us the only
thing I had, but he was in Wisconsin,
you know, I'm about out here on my
own. And Holly, I remember saying like,
if you want to, when they're showing
the be the best you can, brother,
you need to go to Jersey and
mark and Matt already text me.
You're more than welcome to come out and
train whenever you want. At the time,
I had a girl who had a kid and my family
and the coaching was my dream job,
still my dream job. And
I loved that. You know,
I didn't want to leave that for anything.
You coaching wrestling at the junior
college level. And I remember, uh,
that was the only made 220 bucks a week,
but I worked other jobs to
make my dream a reality.
That's why I want to do and fight and
I'm Holly's like if you want to be the
best, you want to win the show,
the best opportunity you got man,
you need to go to Jersey.
Like I know you got guys there but even
of my guys told me after the show you
need to leave cause we can't do
anything for you. But I didn't want to,
I was so grounded today. I didn't want to
leave that. That's what I knew. And uh,
when all he said, Bro, you got to go,
but I could never live in Jersey is
too fast paced. I'm a country boy.
I like outdoors and this
hunting and stuff like that.
Like you need to get the Jersey
brother if you want to be the best,
if you don't want to be the best, stay
where you are. I remember telling my mom,
like I said,
I need to go to Jersey.
I'm mom said when I was in high
school my senior year, she said,
you get the opportunity ever to leave.
I want you to go far away.
Did you think about going anywhere else?
Like go on the roof of sport permanently
or, and that was a thought? Yeah,
I thought, but he didn't
have the rest have been, but
that was about it. You know,
I'm a wrestling base and I fell in love
with the way Frankie and I'm trained.
I loved that I was looking for something
like that. Mark Fiori had that,
but when he left, had nowhere else to
go. I was thinking and my mom said,
that's what the best is. You need to go
be the best. And all my brother was like,
Yo,
let's go Mark Henry such unique guy that
when when people start training with
him and realizing like what he is and
then comparing them to other people,
it makes them think like, wow, this
guy's got something very unique.
Like all of what you're talking
about is systems and all this.
The stuff that he writes in the notes
and like Brendan Schaub was telling me
that he trained with him for one fight
and he said when he went down there,
he said like, it looks like, oh
look, an eye opening experience.
Like he didn't know that a
coach could be that good.
Yeah. And you know, it's crazy part, the
reason why mark isn't known the most.
Cause you're like Freddie Roach.
She got Duke Roufus all these big
game named guys. Um, what's, uh,
the guy hard knocks three 65 or Kamora
who? Smith, what's the coach's name?
Uh, Henri Hooft. Hendry
who if they always got it,
but that's all they do throughout the day.
So you see them because they work with
so many fighters and it's like that's all
they do is coach them. And May,
you know, mark has a pizza man.
When I first got it and they said that
I didn't know he had them own a pizzeria
and he's just say after respond,
like I ain't got time to go make the
dough five minutes to go to a job,
make money. Right. Yeah. And then his
older pieces of pizzeria and that's his,
that's his passion. Like when
practice is over, it needs to,
we just start at nine 30 I need to be
out of my shot by 11 and then I got to
work with this guy at four 30 or
five so he just missed twice a day.
You got seven o'clock in the morning
or four o'clock in the afternoon,
but through today he's at the pizzeria.
That's his baby.
His father in law gave that to him.
He's passionate about,
he loves it that his
whole families and he,
you go there and you'll
see the family bond.
He treats all his employees like family.
That's his dream is you got to respect
that because he doesn't miss work because
of this. Even with my fights,
whatever, he'd come out Thursday,
like I gotta be at the pizzeria all week,
but I'll be there Thursday
night or Friday morning.
Sometimes they show up Saturday
fight that I got a catering job.
I can't make your bro,
but I'm a video chats you and
tell you what we need to work on,
videotape this workout with such and
such and I'll tell you what we need to
tighten up.
And I beat her Saturday morning or Friday
night and we were working as much as
we can before the fight. I was like
a character in a movie. Exactly.
And the fact that he's that passionate
about that and the MMA and I remember
driving with him to one of our amateur
guys fights. He's driving Washington.
Felt like coach you watching
the road or you watch it?
Like I got to wash this girl's fight
cause uh, we got Katelyn Juke Kagan,
one of her my fights while
he fights while driving,
he gave him a piece of paper and a pen
and take this down. Like what? He's like,
I need you to write this down for me.
This is what I need. So He's driving,
watching film and he started calling out
stuff. I'm writing it down. He's like,
God, that's the stuff I need
to remember for a fight.
But he doesn't have the time. Most guys
have to sit and do that through the day.
He picked me up from the piece of
real change and we hit the road.
So he's like breaking film and you see
somebody so passionate that can do the
things he does and he got so many
fighters. Like you say what the codes.
We got the Russians, we got the
resilience and you got us and everybody,
the Russians,
their stuff is in Russian.
That mean this guy is taking time to
learn rush. You're going to the basement.
He has like translation watts. Yes,
that he understands Russia now.
So he write down what does he learned?
Russian,
he learns Russian just to
help these guys with stuff.
Jesus here likes to hear responding about
how that show over there some how to
chose what's that and here
like what I mean very good.
Like what the why the resilience hauling
the and that was he using like Rosetta
stone and he just have, like I said,
they write it down what this mean,
like basic stuff and they write down
how you say it in Russian. Oh Wow.
Mark is up. He's a mad scientist.
He got so many things going on.
He can't remember the direction you're
going in and you'd be driving. He's like,
ah, what am I going? But
when it comes to colts,
he knows all 10 to 12 fighters.
Every co in everybody has a different
language in different names.
Is named after our family or your dog
or something happened. We was a kid.
Everything revolves around
something that happened and he,
every fighter has different coats.
He knows everybody's,
we line up for rounds at the Nica
tones in the cage. He's in occasion.
Frankie Marlin come in now I saw a
Portuguese, then Caitlin come in.
Then it's all stuff related to her. Then
I come in how to speak Portuguese. Yes,
he has Eric codes in
Portuguese, everything and
mark is a wizard. Like I said,
when I say he's a mad scientist,
you don't know any other coaches that
take the time to learn and stuff that he
does to make his fighters the best.
He ain't worried about that.
He wants to win and all that,
but he wanted to make sure we are in sync.
We indicates we talking,
it's a foreign language.
Like that's why I'm the global
fight you here. Uh, Dan Hardy,
one of them say like there's no point
in turning the corners corner cause we
don't know where to saying everything.
And like three fights later,
I won't even know what he said cause
we didn't have been to so many coats.
I got to go back and think
like what was that again?
Did you ever get to a point where he's
yelling something out and you don't know
what the code is? No,
no cause muscle memory.
Because when we hit pads is never a one
two across like what would you say it's
not one to like what would it be if
it's some important cause like uh,
like for you one would be like,
I'm trying to think of only an old one.
So I'm trying to think, uh, sync, sync.
That's,
I can't read what language it was,
but I think that was a hooker or whatever.
I can think and not us thing.
But that was how you say it
in their language. Oh, but
what about for you? Like,
what's that weird like?
He would give you like posting different
language Friday and went through
everything in English. Now we're gonna
switch it up. Still working on Russia now.
Last time I was working in a rush and
stuff so it's Kinda like he was giving you
Russian coach. I was like, I'm
learning too. You know what I'm saying?
Like I said pretty how to show.
I know that me and very good now it
certain things you say to them and you
figure it out. That's so crazy. So
what, what is this logic behind that?
He doesn't want anybody learning the
codes. Just keep you on your toes,
keep you on your toes, keep your
all. He never skin comfortable.
One thing cause you get into a habit,
one habit.
How are you going to get condoms or
God knows what the eyes close, right?
You always gotta learn something new.
It keeps you hungry. Like my friend,
he used to make me come over ice,
do mitts on Friday night and
then we'd go to the movies.
But we do mix from four to five
30 when I first was learning,
he would make me sit a table. He showered,
I showered, whatever. He goes shot.
I had to study my coats and when it
come down he'd be watching TV, whatever.
He'd be in the kitchen. He take
the paper from me, he says I'm out,
and I had to tell him what it meant. Like
one, two, once you left, kick, whatever.
So he would say whatever the code was
and I had to know it. I messed it up.
He bring notepad back.
I keep studying and I was like,
like he take you in like that now.
He took me in like a son.
I'm 12 hours from home. He could dog
me out. I could have just been there.
What does this, Jamie, is that corner
transcript from Eddie's fight. Okay,
let us some codes. Yes. 73
on the knees. 73 on the knee.
73 on the knee. You're too much
in the front. You too much. Yeah.
Chain chain, chain chain.
Hands Up, Chin down.
What could be changed? Take downs
together. It could be anything.
It could be anything. Yeah. No, no.
Is Change. Change, change and down.
They ain't take her. He told him something
for standing as the stand in code.
Like you can send out three with the
fucking 73 he keeps saying 73 what does
that mean? I couldn't 73 that could be
anything for Eddie because Eddie don't,
let's see.
Some people,
only six to 26 73 like I said,
weird. He's so he's got numbers for
him. I mean we all got numbers. Yeah,
we all have numbers. But if you do want
a coat once a combo, he makes it a comb.
It was a single thing he would say,
but it's not the number normal one,
two or it might be sink or if it's a,
what's another?
He said he gave me Croatian
once. Correlation. Yeah,
that took me forever. I don't know this,
but just like Russia. It's tech and now,
but it's like you don't know it but
she learned that. Let me ask you this.
So say if you got a fight scheduled now,
so someone UFC calls you up and they say,
hey Corey, we got another one for you.
It's an eight weeks with this guy.
So that's when you'll start
learning the newest codes.
We've worked codes right away off
the last fight. He said we can,
we sit down and watch
the fight and we hear it.
We call so and we see how we're
reacting to it. After that fight,
then you go to a new code.
We worked in new stuff right away.
As soon as you start tracking
new code already changed it up.
So when it's time to get in the camp,
that's the thing.
It's like people that don't
stay in the gym after a fight,
when they first get in, can't we spend
the first half of camp getting in shape?
Right? Same thing. So if
we don't have the codes,
then we have to first spend the first
four or five weeks just trying to
understand each other.
I'm not really hitting past comments up.
He'll say something and I throw a cross
when he made a hook or I throw a kick,
you know,
what are you doing?
I was a jail like I don't know what we
spend that first time just shadowboxing
cost, figuring out, figuring
it out for a few weeks.
We watched him film together and we go
back like you see how you did it when you
did this one when it was this language.
That's it.
This is in that language so it's
just like study hall in College.
You figuring it out and he has codes for
football, footwork as well. Everything.
Everything. Every, you would never hear
him. You will never hear him say shot.
You're in every home.
Say Jack,
you're an airy him say head movement and
so it's all in different languages and
where did he learn all this from?
His own system than the camera ass.
I never asked. That's why I
don't ask questions. I just
do it. That's smart. Smart.
If you talked
to Brennan Shop,
shop shop was blown away by it.
It's like I've never
seen anything like it.
Rashad Evans said the same thing
came down when he fought Sam Alvey.
I remember that can't, and we linked
up and trained after he hit like Bro,
he said, I don't even know if
I've been, if I even did there,
I won the world championship.
But mark make it feel like I'm a rookie.
Like I don't know what I'm
doing. Well, you're talking to,
he said he was saying codes and I
was like doing everything wrong.
And in my mind it's kind of like you
start doubting yourself because you can't
get it right. But by the end of
it, you do it so much. Like I said,
it's tandem dance.
Well,
there's something about guys who take
things to a totally new level and that's
what he seems to do, you know, with his
coaching, he loves it. And he can tell,
you could tell, you could tell the
way he treats fighters, the way he,
the way it corners
fighters. And you know, man,
you guys got a fucking incredible
camp right now. I mean,
everybody saying we've got a team, we've
got a family, and for the July when the,
you know everyone's going to
be on four July Mark's house.
Everybody's in fighting.
If you've been there and train with us,
you get an invite. Hey Bro,
if you had that weekend,
the week before next week four is your
lie. We're doing a big party in my house.
Come on, Bro. I got to go back to such
and such. Well, you can make it back, bro.
Open fight.
You're more than welcome to come hang out.
We'd love to have you there. You know,
I remember when I was in Wisconsin,
like we hung out with Anthony Pettis and
Duke Roufus and all those Ufc guys that
in the gym, but I don't ever
remember seeing them outside.
Like we say in the fight I was,
I'd never seen him outside of the gym.
It's not that way in a house.
Like I was talking to Frankie last weekend
was all eating or something or when
it was finished training, stretching. He
said something about a party. I'm like,
I still ain't never been invited
here. New Year's parties. Like, Bro,
it's always open and like everybody's
invited to my house. You just never came.
I was like, oh. He's like,
you know where I live?
Your wife over my house all the time.
You just never came. It's always open.
It was like you like, we know
where each other live. You know,
I had my weight and invite everybody over.
Everybody show up.
So how did he get in
touch with the Russians?
Like how does the beat get over there?
I think what Ali. Ah, that makes sense.
I mean most of our guys
come from a highly,
I think everybody on the team is managed
by Eileen now set for a blind fighter.
But like I say, except for who?
Caitlin's you Kagan. I'm a fighter.
But you call her blind father. That's
her name. That's her mom fighter.
Casey killer. Casey. I call
him cause he's ruthless.
She has received little pretty good.
Then I've seen it like not guys out at
times in the gym really multiple times.
I'm very interested in Marlin, Marlin
Mariah's versus Henry the birthday boy.
Happy Birthday Marlin. Today's
birthdays, birthday. Happy Birthday. Mom.
Even though it's on speaker night.
He was one of those guys when he was
fighting for world series of fighting.
I was very interested in him
coming over to the UFC. I was like,
this guy's got legit skills,
something special. And he would,
he was smashing people, but it wasn't,
it wasn't, he wasn't crushing cans.
He was beating real good guys and the
way he was moving and the things he was
doing, I was like, this
guy's world class. Yeah.
I took Tamale and on the shelf he was
the one that helped me understand the way
the pro with the manager and the
payments. And I didn't, I had nice,
I knew nothing. Like I said, I was in the
gym. He taught me to hide stuff, work.
We sit in a sauna and he was telling
him about Ali. It's like, oh bro,
he's a good guy. Cause I
wasn't, I didn't know this guy.
Well I'll help you out this and this.
And I asked them like,
what'd you think about Eileen? So
he's my man, he's great brother.
This isness you know,
here's the way it works cause you get
your purse and you break a certain
percentage off. These people take the
percentage and then we've got the camp.
This,
he was bringing me to how their camp work
before I was coming out there so I had
an understanding like how
to get paid like you, you,
they going to offer you is if you get
to UFC at first sight off 10 and 10 or
this organization is this and this.
Here's time.
Like you just can't let people take
advantage of things I didn't know. Right.
You know, cause Marlin was just a super
friendly, he's a nice guy, family guy.
Like now I,
if I went home right now I'm sure him and
his wife might be able to with my wife
and the baby just hanging out
with the puppy. They just,
we just a tight knit family like that.
He just looks awesome bro.
What's going on with you in a fight? Like
I heard this, I heard that, I saw this,
I saw that. Don't let people
get to you. This isn't this.
Don't let them talk you into doing this.
Don't let somebody get to you where you
react like this. Keep your head brother.
They're like, you're good. You're going
to be the champ. But I've seen you train.
I know what you do. I know what you're
capable of. You're, you're the good,
you're translating so well from
what you were to where you are now.
So having to, like I said that he's
one of my, him and Frankie Eggo,
Frankie Edgar and my two mentors
in the fight game, you know,
couldn't get two better mentor. I need a
question from Amy. Got, I've messaged him.
And then you got Eddie Alvarez as well.
I don't see Eddie as much as heat mat
comes up like three, four times a week.
But I see Frankie and Marlin every day.
How does any like being over at one FC?
I think they treat, I never
asked him about, you know,
I'm not the type to ask questions. I don't
like being in other people's business.
So I don't ask, what do you think
about this way? You think about that?
He told me when he came back, uh, from his
first trip, he's like, bro, it's crazy.
They treated me like king it. What do you
mean? He was like, uh, me and Jamie flood.
They're like, yeah, that plane I
was on look nice. Like Yeah Bro,
32,000 something for a ticket. And I
was like, what? Damn, that's crazy.
Like that's each 82,000.
I'm like that for,
it was like some Asian airline
first class and he like,
and they gave us like steaks and how it
was amazing. It was great. It was good.
And that's all I ever heard.
All I hear is good things. Yeah.
All here's good things about
the way they treat the fighters,
the mentality the shot tree has and
the way he runs the organization. Very,
very impressed. Like I said, it's an up
and coming. I'm glad it's doing well.
When it first started to say,
oh, it's not going to be around,
they're not going to have backers.
They throwing too much money
right in the get go in the way.
But now here we are six years later when
they started doing or bigger worldwide,
I mean, they're gigantic and
people making money like, Hey,
I know he was telling one of our teammates
that wasn't a PFL turning at 85 but
not doing 85 this year. He's like, what
am I gonna do now? I heard Eddie say,
I mean, I can have my guy I talked to
you, we can try and get you a new one.
And I heard him saying like, Bro, he told
me I can make some good money over it.
I'm trying to do that. Hey gotta
worry about you and your family, Bro.
Do what's best for you and
yours. So well, I mean worldwide,
I think they're on a collision course
with the UFC in terms of like notoriety
and popularity in Asia. It's already
bigger. You know, it's, it's something,
it's something special.
And you know,
you see what the guy that that knots
you can God that uh, Eddie fought,
they have world class fighters and
those are, that's a world. I mean
you knock on Eddie Alvarez, you're a world
class fighter and a first round. Yeah,
yeah. Very impressive. And the, even
the guy that mighty mouse fought,
he gave him trouble guys good. You
know, they got good fighters over there.
Real world class fighters. There's
so many good fighters now. You know.
And then also they have, you know,
yachts and Clive's fighting over there.
Nicky hold skin, they got
worldclass kickboxers envoy,
tie fighters fighting in.
And then even there,
even doing grappling matches.
I mean I love what they're doing together.
Well that's all I did the kickboxing,
MMA but now,
and it had two different rings for but
wanting to do it all in one on one night
as I knew I made a now's the kickbox and
I ain't got grappling and going back,
it's cool to keep you on your toes.
The only thing I don't like,
cause I was the earliest
fucking tomorrow morning,
right? Like two, three o'clock. I
set an alarm to get up to see it.
You gotta take the good with Singapore
or wherever they are in different
countries, whatever they,
they hold their events.
I just think it's so important for
fighters to have options to have so many
different places to have Bella tour.
And you know now that like Rory
McDonald been over the bell at tour and
kindergarten was saucy and you know,
world class guys and Ryan Bader
as a heavyweights, a beast.
Crazy. See, knock out fade or that
first round you're like, what the fuck?
Amazing doing his thing.
I'm happy formal Davis.
I'm just happy to see that
fighters have options. UFC yeah,
it's good for the UFC.
It's good for everybody.
For Mine, people say, I say,
Oh did you ever think about going below
two oh one and my mind is great fighters
everywhere right now. I still think the
number one and all of his in the UFC,
number one martial arts in USC and right
now that's my goal. That's all great.
But I'm here to be the best.
I can go to one and make a killing.
I can go to belch and
get my sponsors back.
But I'm in no rush to leave here
because I want to be the best.
Like after I proved that there was
nothing else, and then it's like, okay,
now I'm ready for the money,
then that's maybe an option.
But there's no confidence in terms
of prestige. There's no context.
If you get the UFC title, you're the best.
That's it. There's no question like, oh,
what about the ability for this, this
and this? Because the Bella to a chimp,
Wellesley, Jon Jones,
and especially on one
and your division,
you know in your division you have
one of the best guys of all time,
if not the best guy of all time champion.
So when you see a guy like John
at the top of the heap,
is that,
is that motivating to you to just ramp
up and even harder because you realize
that the guy who is a champion of your
division is not just the best light
heavyweight of all time.
Maybe the best martial artist of all time.
There ramps up so much like I,
well I'm riding the bike in my basement.
I got the airdyne bike and a stationary
bike and I got the project and I'm down
there. The only thing on fight
pass and I'm watching a fight pass.
I'm usually watching Jon Jones,
you know to see him dominate other
guys and that you just hear that bite.
You can hear the,
the pedals are pretty old head getting
until I can give them raw some crazy and
like I don't even be looking down the
clock where I can just hear her, the air,
the fan picking up right now.
I didn't realize it till like it goes
a break and I slow it down and a heart
race and I was just watching
them just like, like
if I want to get to, I got to, I
got to beat him to be the best.
I need to work hard.
What's your take on him?
You can't take away what
he does in the sport.
What does his outside his personal
life, that's all he say. She say,
I have my words after
the California stuff,
we went to two 26 or whatever it fight.
It was in Vegas and got moved here because
his lifestyle and drug tests and all
the extra stuff, however you want
to code it up, his past, you know,
I'm done with it.
I had my words there,
the fact he kept using
God and Jesus and this,
this and this and I'm a god fearing guy
who read my Bible every morning and I
don't like the fact that you can,
that he would do that. And I'm like,
I said I want it now.
But at the time my words was the fact
that he did that and then at the same time
I want to interview and so I
want to thank God and it's,
that kind of rubbed me wrong.
And then we flew on a plane
together and like I said,
I saw the way he was acting
when he came on a plane.
Like we not doing this because of him,
like all that at a time bothering me
and I was a pent up anyone else on mills
going into that fight?
That was something on my shoulders because
I had posted something cause when a
UFC called me right before I got
on the flight, they were like, oh,
don't come all the way to Vegas now I
got my wife, she's eight months pregnant,
like she's 30 weeks, whatever. She can't
travel after this. She's struggling.
We all them bags and y'all call me and
I'll say, don't come this and this.
Go back home. We're gonna fly you out
again. Like I'm not doing this again.
And then when they get to the, well we
can get you here but we get you to Cali,
but we can't take your wife.
Like what? Like, well you,
we pay your ticket and
coach ticket like no,
fuck that all because Jon Jones is that,
that's what got me mad though.
So they were trying to save money,
not flying people because we was,
we was literally walking down the runway
to the plane when they call him the
cheese, can I turn around? But
then when we got like, okay,
you come here but we can get you to Cali,
but we couldn't get your,
your wife to Cali.
Like my wife is 30 weeks pregnant.
She's here when she's coming like,
well we don't know what to do because
you bought her ticket, isn't it?
Like what do you mean you don't know
what to do? Get her nose ticket.
Like I pay with my family. What about
the people that's on the way right now?
Like all they gotta find their own way
and that made me weak fight week of the
fight. The thing of the things
that you have to think about,
you know fucking with,
that's the last thing I was worried
about and then I get there and they said,
when you get, make sure you got your
workout if you don't have your work.
I scheduled the pie set already.
As soon as you get there, go do it.
I did mine like a month and a half
ahead of time. I'm all, I'm like I said,
I'm puncturing. Like I like having stuff
done. I'm getting ready to go to Pei.
I'm packing my bags and I get a call.
Oh, you can't come to the pie. Why?
John just came in and said he went to
work out so we closed the gym down.
You're not allowed.
Y'all called me two months ago,
told me to set my schedule
to come ahead of time.
I'm really getting ready to walk to my
Uber that's outside and you say I can't
come now like a, sorry.
Nothing we can do as John.
Why can't you work out at the same place
with John's work and did the same thing
when kindness there and I'm there
in the summer and kind of show up.
They come into there but you got to
leave like what? Just wrote really?
You're all getting condoms. Have his car
parked up on the sidewalk. Come on. Yeah,
they have security guards block
the stairs off and everything.
Tello. Yes, exactly.
You walk out and like it hurts
somebody saying big place. Yeah.
But you can go to the
cardio room and the waste,
but you can't use the upstairs with
the cage in the bag and stuff is,
you can't use them if he's in the
cafeteria there. So you can't go up there.
Oh fuck. Is that about acid jazz
to people? I don't know my piece.
I'm an independent contractor
sir. But yeah, like that stuff,
it kind of rubbed me wrong and
that's when it was kinda like,
if I was a champ I wouldn't want that.
I want people to be at to see what I'm
doing in security. I don't know. You know,
you got to think about how much
death threats that guy must get,
how much shit he must take. You know, he's
as popular as he is, as famous as he is.
Maybe just has overzealous security maybe.
And they just want to tighten it down.
So they didn't want anybody up there.
They kept,
I was so that was the first time
I've ever cursed at a UFC employee.
I was Kurt like going off like y'all been
bugging me to change my whole workout
schedule. Fight Week. I'm cutting weight
too. You know, like it's not just John.
Yeah, like we understand of it. I don't
give a fuck about of I don't care.
What are you doing?
I need to go up there and get a workout.
My coaches meeting me there from the
airport but we can't do anything about it.
Korea and the guy kept hanging
up because I was going on.
That is when they called
her back and I was like, Yo,
and then people would hit me up like
I'm glad you actually voicing yourself.
I'm hearing around the PR now,
everybody talking about how you're
mad and somebody texted like,
I'm glad you were actually speaking out
because everybody else kind of like,
okay, like no. Like, okay. Then if
it wasn't for my wife being there,
I probably went checked.
You're saying,
but I see the way she's struggling and
carry this belly around and she's hurt
eight months. She just give birth
at any time. So the stresses,
I'm sure it's like all
that and my baby's milk,
it was revved me up and my wife can't
like Cory, just stop, calm down.
It'll be okay.
This isn't this like the fact of being
okay as the fact that they led in one
person dictate at all. Like we're all
equal and I treated it like a number.
He's Jon Jones but we're number
4,722 right. You know what I mean?
I don't like that he's John. I'm
core. Like I was telling them,
we all know right here reason.
I love rose number units cause I've never
seen her that from her. She's a champ.
But you would see her and she act just
like rose before when she was in Invictus
did.
She hasn't changed.
I don't want no special treatment from
her or from anybody. If I was a champ,
treat me the same. You know what I mean
is some people are different. Like I said,
I don't know if it's John or his camp
that was doing that or UFC is doing or
purity or what,
but it rubbed me wrong that
we aren't equal anymore.
No, that's understandable. But that's
also got to give you some motivation.
Exactly.
Told him in the area of the wine,
I'll sit on the plane and I was really
directly behind Jon Jones and I see a
head Bob and I was just looking,
I looked at my wife and she's like
struggling like falling asleep but a shrug
and fall asleep. I looked at the top
of his head, the back of his head.
I was just like,
it's time for a change of the torch.
I think my brother always said like,
you're good and you know
you can beat everybody.
But I feel like when I come to those
top guys like John Johnson guts,
you doubt yourself just a little bit.
You ain't sure that you can get to me.
You know you're good.
But you feel like this was before
like before they leave fight,
you get there and you, you feel like
you don't think you're ready for that.
But I'm checking her. Watch you bro. I
know that you made it. You can do it.
And when I down I saw him Baba
and all the frustration going through
my mind. Six o'clock in the morning.
We had to get up and catch a plane
cause this guys, isn't this, it's,
they show up on time. He still was
late to that and it was just like I,
if I'm the champ, I don't want this. Yeah.
I mean I don't want no special treatment.
If you tell me what sign up ahead
of time and keep your schedule,
I expect that if we get down
to scale first, come first,
first come, first serve.
If I show up late,
put me in the order I am,
don't put me up front because I'm the
champ because I was the first and second
person there. I'm always just scale
and John was walking down the stairs,
fully dressed.
We went back to commission room and I
remember people in the blue shirt came and
said, hold up, hold up. And
all of sudden John come in,
he could do all the paperwork.
He went on a scale and he was out.
He was last present. Donna, how's it? He's
first like it wasn't that big of a deal,
but the fact that I don't like that. Well
it's because he's headline in the card,
right? Yeah. Giving them
special treat, everything.
That's what he kept saying
is John Jones there.
How I got the phone with this John Jones.
They hang up like, I don't like that.
It's still, he's still a person. Well,
he's the greatest person
to be Corey Anderson.
Hundred percent change the tide. There's
Corey Anderson, but treat me. Know Him.
Don't get me treatment. Beautiful.
That you have that attitude. What?
When you look at John and
you look at John's skills,
like what do you think you need to do
if anything different in your life or in
your training or where do you need to get
to where you think you could beat him?
Just keep getting better.
Like does Leo,
the Tfa fight must've been a
big boost for 100% every fight.
Every fight.
Even the ones I lost,
it all been the boost
because you go back and see,
tell me a fight that I've been
getting beat up, Joe. Right?
I've never been a fight where somebody,
they're all core, you're too smart,
you're not good.
There's never been one fight in my career
where somebody straight manhandled me
and push me around. You know what I mean?
They talk about this, this and this. Uh,
he's the greatest sense.
He's greatest that I was watching the
UFC main event last night in hotel.
They had the Glover or shy fight and
that's how I'm going is this and this and
this and up and gloves. This
clover that Clovis, Clovis at,
I think I beat that guy.
You know,
and just like you're talking about hope
they don't give it a little t or Johnny
Walker a little TV. He's
super good. This isn't this,
but at the same time I was thinking,
and you said it, but what about Korea?
And I was like, there we go. Finally
somebody like, all these guys are talking,
they talk about how good these guys
not in beat them all. You're like,
I'm not gonna come onto the radar.
And they don't expect me to do
nothing because I lost the Gi bill.
I would say my third or fourth
fight in UFC two years of my career.
You know what I mean? Uh,
Jimmy man with Jimmy met,
I was told we on the way here
to Jimmy man was the only fight.
I would say the guy beat me.
He didn't man handle me,
but in my head from his highlights and
it's all like you said on Instagram,
reading comments and I let what people
were saying and reading and seeing him
get in my head to think if this got
touches me, he's going to put me out.
And when you're going into
a fight thinking that I
literally got touched and my
mind was already set. Like
if I get hit, I'm going out.
And like I think subconsciously,
like I had myself so
doubted that when he hit me,
my mind just like in panic kind of shut
down because I remember when I hit the
mat, like I wasn't Algebra,
I don't remember I was out.
But I remember seeing his feet walk away.
And I remember when I came through
clearly and I thought to myself like it
happened. Is that what I'll
put them on my, if I got hit,
it happened and after that, that
was it. It was like I can take,
I can take it to anybody.
And I think Osp was more dangerous
than Jimmy because he can kick,
he was explosive and this isn't the amp
punch now did everything right and just
slipped into the punch the wrong way. But
I was, man, Halan don't put three rounds.
And I mean it's simple mistakes because
I didn't have the discipline yet.
In three years of my career I hadn't
learned the discipline and focus that it's
a 15 minute fight.
I can win 12 minutes of it all.
But one mistake and it's all gone.
Well, the experience of making those
mistakes and realizing what they are and,
and then when those moments come up again
and you deviate from the game plan and
you do go to your right and you do move
the wrong direction, you know, you'll,
you'll catch yourself.
You'll realize it's
the experience of competition
for a fighter is there's
nothing that substitutes
it. He could have great talent.
You can have a great mindset.
But the experience of
competition is like nothing else.
And one thing that I've seen from you
is that every time you have had losses,
you've gone back to work
and come back better.
Like you made significant
jumps in between each fight.
That's why you like when we're
talking about fighters and I said,
well what about Corey Anderson?
Because people do leave you out of the
discussion but they don't leave you out
of discussion because you're not good.
They for whatever reason,
leave you out of discussion because
maybe because you're a polite,
soft spoken guy and you, you haven't
been knocking people out like that's the,
the the knock on you.
If there is a nine but you're winning,
winning is with fighting.
The key is winning.
It's not knocking people out or some many
people. The key is winning. I can you,
when can you beat worldclass guys?
You shown you could beat worldclass guys
and the fact that you've done this with
just seven years total training
is pretty fucking incredible.
Pretty amazing man.
You read your voice down the air.
I can say it all day and nobody is.
You shouldn't even say it at all.
Let me say it for you,
is I got to get off of me.
Didn't realize I'll fuck off social
media post and run. Just Post and run.
Because it's like we were saying before,
it's just not a healthy way to consume
things. So they're just the random cause.
P two is too many people out there that
are bored or maybe they're not healthy
mentally and they're just,
they would like to fuck with your head.
And they see a guy like you,
especially at guy who is on that
elite athlete fighting in the UFC.
There's so much jealousy and pettiness
and spit in sports fans are weird like
that. They'll call some guy who was making
$20 million a year of fucking loser,
but it's crazy. But you sit at
home on food stamps watching crazy,
but their words,
although they mean nothing,
if you see them in print and it's about
you, it can get you to go, hey, hmm.
And that might fuck with you while
you're running. Fuck that guy. You know?
And there might be 30 of those guys.
And if you, you go downhill spiral.
If you have a weak mind and you don't
understand how to compartmentalize and how
to,
how to look things objectively,
if you don't see what that is and you
start I five I was saw him, I'd say this,
so come see that shit to my face. And you
started getting involved in that stuff.
This just a giant waste of resources,
a giant waste of energy.
It doesn't do you any good at all.
Especially when look at what
you're surrounded with, man.
You telling me it's all
family elite fighters,
some of the best guys in the world.
You have one of the best coaches on the
planet earth. Many of Ricardo Almeida,
one of the best Jujitsu
coaches on the planet earth.
You're with some elite world class
fighters. You're all tied together.
That should be all of your mental diet,
all of your communication, camaraderie,
all your interaction with people.
It should be that cause you got
top of the food chain. Like,
why fuck with all these scavengers online
and cannibals and fucking zombies and
that's what you're dealing with when
you get into those comments sections,
you don't know who these people are. You
know what I mean? It could be anybody.
True story just for a fighter.
You the mentality,
and this is another thing that
I wanted to ask you about.
Your mentality is so fucking important.
Do you use a mental coach and you,
have you ever been hypnotized? If you
ever worked with a mental coach at all?
Only thing I did different this year
was the BrainTap a brain call him a
physical therapist thing and you
put the sound on this kind of,
it's like Kinda like hypnosis and they
got like flashing lights that you can go
take a nap, whatever.
And it's kind of like,
well this isn't like they say you listen
to Rosetta stone or something before
you go to bed.
When you wake up,
it's in your mind as you
heard it at the same thing.
So I take a nap and I put it in.
It's always positive thoughts.
It's like take a deep breath.
Just, and this and it slowly,
it's just you hear it talking,
he's speaking and he's slowly stops,
but you see the light's still going
off but is there and you push it and
forwards.
You can hear him like very lightly talking
in the background and I take like an
APP like 30 minutes. So what are
the like the Buddha is the lights.
How does it work? I think it's like,
just got to hear Jamie's got it.
Because you want to pull one over.
Yeah,
I think it's like pulling a BrainTap
headset. Yeah, there you go.
And I think the lights and stuff is
just keep your focus to your body isn't
completely sleep or song.
Let me see this.
It says uses unique frequencies of light
and sound for brainwave entrainment in
just 22 minutes of deep relaxation.
Your brain will be guided to relax,
proven scientific techniques allow your
brain to rest and allows your brain the
rest and recovery that it needs by
reaching various states of consciousness,
reboot,
clean the slate of unimportant and of
the unimportant and reinforced the most
valuable information for better
memory and brainpower. And revitalize.
Our sessions are designed
to build resilient,
build a resilient mind and fit
body from life. Huh. Anyway,
that and float tank.
That was another thing I I relax cause
the only thing I had a problem with,
I used to, you're always going to have
dreams. You know, if I have a bad spine,
whatever, I'm thinking negative. So when
I go to bed or have a negative dream,
have a dream, I got to take
down 10 times. I had a dream,
I got hit hard in practice.
I had a dream,
I got hit hard and I put it out nice
to feel like and going into fights.
If I had one of them dreams,
like I remember just before
the Gian volante files.
After I Fall Justin,
I went home at first and I went to sleep.
I woke up and had the dream.
I fought Gian Volante next not floss,
a split decision.
And in my mind I remember going into that
fight in that stave vivid in my head,
I'll lose, he's got split
decision somehow. My dream. No,
I was fighting Jabil onto the next,
it had lost split decision and I
think that's why in the third round,
even though everybody was
saying like you were saying,
the leg kicks and everything and when
it came up they showed a scorecard.
There's like,
I guess I was winning on the scorecards,
but in my mind I thought I was getting
defeated and I had to go harder and go
hard and I was getting beat up because
in my dream is so vivid in my mind.
So I got greedy and coaches just
kept saying like just oof. Oof.
I was just doing the most trying
to hit him as much as I could.
And you kept saying it
and I watched the video.
You said the best offense
is the best defense.
If Cory can get hit Gian can't throw
anything back. So that was my mind.
If I get it this round ten
eight there's no way I lose.
So I ain't hit him as much as
I can as many times as I can.
Maybe I'll put them out and I
got overzealous and got caught.
And then when the scorecards came on
and said I was winning and there was no
reason for me to do all that in
my mind going into that fight,
I remember all fight with
bad dream kept popping up,
never had another dream losing again.
But that was from December of the year
before and he was stuck in my head for
some, I couldn't let go of it
and then I can't or whatever.
If I had another one that it didn't
show the, uh, the finish of the fight,
but I woke up with direct eight and two
at the time I was a one or [inaudible]
71 [inaudible] 81.
And this was before going into the Tom
Lawler fight and I was nothing like,
fuck,
do I lose this?
And I remember in Vegas he rocked me
in the beginning and I thought for sure
that has given them scroll, kind of like,
here you go, here come that dream again.
Her Andrea again. When I say core answer,
now I've ever gone to a hotel room.
Somebody put a sign on, it said
nine and one now. Congratulations.
And that's been stuck in my head
like, oh gosh, that's what he means.
Nothing and that's my
dreams are just dreams.
I got to get the float
tank helps you float tank,
hit my getting there and relax
like the negative thoughts.
I always do it the week, the last week,
Sunday I do massage. I go to church,
massage,
float tank and there's nothing on my mind,
but the Bible and the Gospel,
I heard that morning I go to
the massage and I fall asleep.
Am I going to that float tank?
I think about what I need to do and the
don't mind songs stop and I'm thinking
about is that fight with victory, winning,
getting my hand raise, whichever way,
dominate, dominate, dominate.
When I wake up that whole week,
I don't have any negative thoughts
because that's what I visually that lasts
three times or work at home and was all
positive thinking and with the brain tap
like my doc, let me take it to the fight
with me so I'm resting between training,
put it on. He gave me his little travel
iPhone where they put it on the brain,
the brain tap and just wake up. Like I say
relax like Avi, I get down on practice,
I'm tired, I'm exhausted. But that
little 15 20 million that which I want,
I use one of my brain
come back to is like,
I feel like I just slept for hours
so much for you.
I been the type, I never believe
any of that stuff like hypnosis,
I never believed it.
But after he let me try it,
like just try once and I tried it and I
actually like it was that my body relax.
I noticed the next day and train like Dang
like this a juicy like I always sugar.
Did you choose to I hate,
it's just my phone. I went to,
I finally realize things I was doing.
I was at lax parents who
Ricardo was saying washing
the small details and he was
like, Bro, you look good
today. And I was thinking like,
I think maybe that BrainTap actually
kind of how I kept doing it.
Put your mind in a good place to learn
things. So you kind of open mind,
you relaxed, you wake up and it's like
the air frill smells a lot fresher.
You hear a bird, it's like, it's
just like I said like hypnosis,
they say it works and I guess that's not,
it's not putting me to sleep a putting
out hip knows hematites but the way it
made me feel like I ain't want to say,
oh I work hypnosis was like I hypnotized.
But subliminal messages,
you don't hear it.
Like if you listen to music and some
in the background, it's in there.
How often are you doing that brain tap?
Well now I haven't done,
I'm about to buy one of those from my uh,
physical therapist.
He got some extra ones he said he'd
get rid of so I can do it more.
But I usually do it when I get in the
camp and I'm old physical therapist place.
They relocated and closed down here so
that's why I haven't done it that much.
But he said, I've got some us, I still
have one at home and you use it everyday.
Not Everyday. I don't want to
get too sucked into it. But yeah,
at least twice a week. Twice a week. I
do it when I go to therapy twice a week.
I got through at once,
once just that last day before I leave.
Just kind of like Whoa, I want to over
water. Look you drink too much water.
It backfire.
So I don't want to do the same thing.
A float tank cause float tank is also
great for the injuries in the body.
You know,
that's how I found it at first.
My shoulders real messed up once a pet
comes to fight and I kept getting Stinger
and I couldn't figure it out. My
physical therapist, she was like,
you need to go try float tank.
I think it'd be really good.
Help you with your other bumps and bruises
and pull off a couple ounces at the
same time cause I'll Epson salt.
Just sit there and try it.
I reached out to the guy and brick in a,
he gave me a little, do I hook you up?
You know you advertise for me
and I'll let you float. Yeah.
So I did it and I liked it.
Like I said,
the Nigga thoughts going into the fact
comes fight. That's where I got the dream.
I got takedown, took down like 10 times
because I had a guy come on, he's like,
I've trained with pay is
really good in wrestling.
This guy was national
champ and he's really good.
He might take her down a couple of times,
but he came out,
Carter Carter Cardio and my mom's like,
I don't wanna get taken down at all.
So I started having dreams.
I was getting taken down like 10 12
times over about pet and that couldn't
happen. And as you see, I end up taking
him down. I didn't want to shoot that.
I just wanted to kill him on the feet.
I ended up taking it down 12
times and I was struck the shit.
Think you were taking them
down because of your dream.
Like you wanted to prove your dream wrong,
like maybe you had that took him down
when it was so easy. I was just like,
I'm just gonna keep doing this.
Hit Him with a couple of punches.
When Gary Did Punch,
take them down cause I'm thinking in my
mind it's got stressed at the Olympic
level. Do you want all American Penn
state, the best school out there?
I'm thinking there's no way he's going
to be easy to take this guy down.
It had to wait till he get
tired and chain wrestle.
I just like one of my
weakest blessed though,
whatever and just blew him off
his feet and I was like, that was,
that was kind of easy.
But it's different when you got a guy
that's used to taking people down,
but nobody shoots on him.
He wasn't used to that young person
that shot him was a Yom blocker, which,
and that's when he was tired.
He finally got to take down.
Everybody else couldn't get it. So
it was like, I'm just gonna try it.
And I went through him. It was
like, Oh man, that was too easy.
I told mark in the corner like
when had my leg in the corner,
you got to defend it.
You got to defend it.
I can feel it feel and we hit the cage
and my wizard was so tightly he had the
leg. I looked at her was like,
and he asked me to come on.
What was your shaking your head like?
He wasn't taking me down.
He's not going to take me down.
I can tell from the way he answered.
I trained with Nica tone
and he was another UFC vet.
He's a fucking monster when it comes
to wrestling. Him and Chris Weidman,
two tubs dudes I've ever arrested and
they haven't made game and I knew when he
answered him he was nothing
compared to those guys.
I just looked at nick or Ricardo shook
my head and nick knew cause he was in the
corner too. He knew he could tell
him my conference. I wasn't worried.
He's not giving me down.
And after that it was over.
So this brain tap thing,
a float tank one week before the fight,
the last week.
What other,
do you have any other rituals that you
do that you make sure you keep your head
and your body in check?
I mean, like I said,
I'm always on physical therapy cause
like I said, my body so beat up,
I haven't competed span ice baths
every Sunday night after I do all that,
I go home and relax. And that night
before I go to bed, 20 minutes in,
fill the tub up. What? I sit there,
I do cryo therapy twice a week,
once or twice a week,
all training camp, um,
therapy twice a week I do a
massage every Sunday. You know,
I got a lady that used to train
at our gym. Amazing. Right.
And everybody's like with Yoga. Yeah,
I do that too. Every once in a while,
like closer to get that flexibility.
Hot Yoga helped me get some pounds off
a little easier so I can wreak Heidrick
more before a spar. I did that
Friday night with Saturday response.
I'm more limber to throw kicks and stuff
on my final spar throughout the week.
So, you know, I got different,
different places and companies I reached
out to and they helped me, I helped him.
That's awesome. So where are you at
right now? They are first of all,
what is going on with the knuckle?
Holy Shit.
That would just glow over his
forehead. I hit him with, here you go.
Put your hand up. This one right in front
of you. Look at that. Knock off folks
or the upper cut on a glow
over in the third round.
Now I remember when mark was calling a
combo, he said, I can't remember. He said,
and I hit him with him with
the right hand, like, oh,
and my brother and I looked down at my
hand up and this finger like stuck out
like that. I remember shaking my
head demark like, nope, we were us.
After he shot shaking hands, slapped
my hand, his hand, his hands mess.
I think I dislocated my finger. He
went in the back. Oh, just this. Okay.
We probably back and I couldn't get it
and we kept trying to just keep them
taped together and keep it straight
and get better and everything.
I remember holding my wife was
like, don't move it. Don't move it.
You got to quit me. I was doing it.
It's like don't exercise mentally.
Like it might hurt now if I get
used to it. It never heard again.
Did you ever go to a
doctor? Yeah, I went in,
I ruptured a tendon and the tendon from
here road all the way up and that study
is, it rolled up and it was already fat
cause I broke this finger and Col. Dot.
So all of this, that's why I was
like curve like when I go down.
So was there anything they
could do for it? Making it,
they said we can straighten out and put
a pin to attach it, but it will take,
I be able to bend my hand like this,
but a decided it'd be kind of like,
it wouldn't bend all the way anymore
if I did that. That's what he said.
Like if you do that, you're going
to be at the fight. You know,
it's Kinda hard cause I guess
the pen is kind of long.
So that makes that joint not bend all the
way. But uh, when I went to the doctor,
they did that. They was like, hold on.
They did an ray and an MRI was like,
that makes no sense. Like this
tendon is how you move this finger.
So how the hell you move your finger and
you know, 10. And I was like, I don't,
when it was taped together,
just kept doing it in Germany
while I was on my vacation.
My wife just kept doing
it extra side and say,
well I guess it's a
good thing you did that.
Cause if he wouldn't have it would've
hired harden up in here and this joint
would have been immobilized.
I won't be able to use it.
But the fact that I kept doing it
while it was fresh, I'm still able
to move it. That's the craziest Logan
Finger I've ever seen in my life.
That's like a triple finger.
That's nuts, man. That is,
that's a wild looking joint. Does that
fuck with you grappling or anything?
Nothing was hard as a rock man.
It doesn't bother me at all. Wow.
It's crazy looking, man. I think it's
a weapon. Now, the glove right here,
if I throw a hook my right hand, right?
Yeah, I suck. Right. It's all calcified,
right? Yeah. Yeah. So, um,
where are you at right now in terms of
like when does the UFC usually come to
you with a, an idea of what, who
are you going to fight next time?
Obviously you beat Latifa.
He was top five. Yeah.
So you're three and five.
What did they,
what did he got you ranked now eighth or
ninth. How's that work? Did you tell him?
Ask him how's, how does Koreans
and night and the top five,
I'm beat the number three and the five.
When I was three, they put me at six.
I don't know,
they put me at six like I
beat Glover and I went to six.
By the time I fought I
was 10 that night in Cali.
I was ranked 10th in and how
the Hell does that happen?
Then I'd be the leader who was six
and I went, or fifth or fourth one.
I went to six and then a
week later I was at seven.
The next week it came out of
that, hey, this makes no sense.
There's no fights happen. Don't even
care what you're clearly top 10.
You know, and whatever number that is. I
mean, it's a, you got a murderer's row.
People in that division,
you know, they, when,
when do you think they'll come to
you with a, an offer for, I mean if
I Gus at a time, like I said,
after filing the microphone,
I don't want to fight anything
else until my babies here.
When the baby's here and
everything's checked out,
I don't have to be in camp and stress
this and this. Once that's all done,
we can talk.
And they called him a couple weeks later
about Gus because he tweeted me and had
them ask me area and I said the same
thing. Like I'm waiting til my baby's Jen.
That was March 15th the due date and
my baby was March 12th it's too close,
not risking it, you know?
Then there's like, all right,
what about June 1st and I was just ain't
letting me kind of finish with my baby
and stuff. I'm not really even
training my home. My wife,
I'm doing a little bit here and there,
but I'm worried about hurting now.
She's been with me ride down this whole
time. That was my time to focus on her,
what she needs.
She didn't want me to away,
so I'm here and they kept calling and kept
calling and I just kept saying, no, no,
no. And they kept asking me. I was like,
oh. And Allie, it was like, I mean,
what are we getting more money if
they give him? My wife was like,
if we can get more, we'll take it
back it. If they give you more,
I'll let you go whenever we can start
camp or whatever. I had to give me more,
we'd do it and they say, oh no, we
were not doing nothing. The right,
we didn't wait.
Let me finish this.
Literally my baby came out and I felt
that. I asked the doctors everything fine.
They did the test.
Everything came back
clear like there's no problems. Don't have
to go to doctors, nothing. She's like,
you're fine. You've got a healthy
baby boy. Congratulations.
Literally pick my phone
up. Tweeted Gus. Gus,
you still want to go June 1st. You want
to do it? I'm going to huckleberry.
Let's go. London. I'll come. Yes, Cory.
You know I wanted to fight. Let's do it.
Ali Call me. It's on his managers call
me. We want to fight. Let's do it.
June 1st same, same pay. No raise, no
nothing. Whatever I was getting, let's go.
It takes Dana.
They literally,
they call me the day before on the way to
the hospital. I get a cough. My leader,
you want to know if you want
to fight, bro. I'm going, wait,
I call you after we figure it out.
I say yes. Less than 24 hours later.
They say no.
We gave him to Anthony Smith.
Now what the fuck y'all call me for
yesterday harassing me all his camp now I
say yes and you're taking it away like
why y'all? What's going on and that.
That made me mad. Then they call me
for Luke Rockhold like I'm not, no,
not taking a step back like I want to
be here for the title. I'll be Luke.
What are they going to say? Cause I
guess if they told Ali, if I beat Glover,
since he was going to fight earlier, that
peer media contingent for title fight,
they gave me a new contract and
everything with all that in it signed it.
Then I let it go.
He need one more fight and it was a guy
make him an Alere fight in at least they
know cause he managed both of us.
Don't you see to Luke Rockhold is a good
fight for you and he's a former dupont,
but it wouldn't do nothing but it would
definitely elevate you in the public
side.
The Guy,
you don't think it would help if no is
what now you would think Galicia chief
would have helped me in
rank and dangle over.
I don't buy that because I think they'd
like rankings. Look, even if it's not one,
one through ten eight in any one of
those guys get fight for the title.
If they get, look, Tiago Thiago
Santos, right? I mean, uh,
he lost the David Branch one
a year ago. Right? Came out.
I beat Pat Cummings or
April 13th or 18th whatever.
Now he's fighting for the title. I mean,
it was a quick ascension from, you know,
devastating knockouts and fighting like
a wild maniac like he does and he's a
wild fighter to watch. Very, very
entertaining guy. That's all it took.
But who was in that?
He didn't have to be the big name guy.
That's thing he'd be on black with you.
I killed on my fourth fight in UFC
beat Jimmy beat Jimmy Mattawan. Um,
stopped him and the other guy,
we're both 85 hours. She didn't,
so he had two fights is because he
had knockoffs and that's the thing.
Like I said, I told him, I know. He
was like, Bro, it's a good fight.
He's the same thing you said.
It's a good fight. Like Ali,
let's look at who I fought.
I beat Glover who was third.
They still didn't put minutes.
How fight?
I'll be a little TV when they say
it's next to beat the champ, whatever.
When I beat him, they still don't give
me the credibility. It's like, oh,
he's washed up now. I was,
I pop her a tweeter. I like,
I apologize to anybody that would be,
because once you lose to me it's
kind of like you're a nobody.
I'm sorry for that time. All their
posts, the thing of the day saying,
oh these guys all failed. They get
six months. I fell for the same thing.
I get two years. I said I'm sorry
Tom Cause you lost to me. I think did
you get the short end of the stick?
I'm sorry though the same thing is half
of that asshole coach when you were in
college is it is in the same way and
that's why motivation back to tweets and
shit cause in my head things
like that that I've been through,
you know what I should learn
but now it doesn't matter.
But in my mind I've voiced my opinion
set coach and when I proved her wrong I
ran his assistant coach later
on in life and he said he's,
he doesn't really like you anymore cause
the guy actually I fall in the ultimate
fighter was his best friend, Kelly
and us, one of his all Americans.
He used to call him back when I was
in college trying to discipline me.
If I like do some shit to piss him off,
he would have Kelly come in and try to
beat me up. Never happened. I'm like,
he couldn't beat me up like that.
He used to get pissed at that.
So the fact that he thought he had like
a hold on me with this transcript and I
got out and then I ended up fighting
Kelly on the show and he said that to him
probably once I, he kill you and him and
May, he could kill you and then we may,
well the opportunity came and I beat
him and somebody told him he like,
he wasn't happy about that. He didn't
like the fact that you beat Kelly.
Like I'm sorry I don't do things for him.
This,
this thing,
what you don't feel like you get
in the respect that you deserve.
It does motivate your dog.
It does give you a little bit
of extra juice in the gym.
I mean, I'm a motivated guy anyway. Highly
motivated. Morning, wake up, open my eyes.
Is it sounding?
Get to work.
So your son's born, the Anthony
Smith common. He had a, you know,
Anthony spent survive against
Jon Jones and you know,
especially early on he looked good,
you know, showed good technique,
showed that he's,
he's really a world class fighter and
I think that they just think that that
would be, he probably said yes when you
said no and they gave it to him, you know,
while you were waiting and
your son was being born.
So now you're just
waiting for another call.
Yeah. But the thing is like, go back to
that real fast. They say yes and he said,
no. I watched his interview,
excuse me, what area? Hawaii.
And they said the day after
he followed Jon Jones,
they called him about
Anthony Smith or about Gus.
So that was about the same
time he was calling me.
So it's kind of like they was just
throwing it out there and Holly said, uh,
I guess they offered it to Johnnie Walker.
Johnnie Walker's manager made a
post I seen that offered us Gus.
Like they was just the only out there for
whoever's gonna be the first person to
say yes,
we have a bunch of people say yes and
then they sit down and they go over it.
Like what looks best for us?
Like what do we have? You know,
I'm not a matchmaker obviously.
What goes on the wrong thing?
Just sort of barely do,
man. I'm telling you,
I know as little as anybody
should in my position,
it's like an independent contractor.
I have no fucking say, look,
if they listened to me,
first of all,
there'll be no more weight cutting and
there'd be a way classes every 10 pounds.
That's what I would, I would fix
that would fix that right away.
I would do the same sort of hydration
testing that one fc does let people fight
it, their natural weight.
So you don't have these
ridiculous 40 pound weight cuts.
Like did you see Brandon Davis
and his last fight? He's a,
he fought at one 35 I didn't
see the weight cut. Fantastic,
but would freeze skinny.
He was a 45 or whatever.
She's giant at one 30 if I'm standing
next to him, like, how the fuck are you?
A 135 pounds?
He does not.
It looks like he's won 70 he's like
Montel Jackson to bring about the same
height as me. It's was like
crazy. Like how a, Hey,
you make one 35 giant hands
like you're a grownup.
Intel's got basketball palm and hand
hands bigger enough. For instance,
the guys he does, they're huge and a
35 pounder man in knitting. Any fights.
Smart too. Smart and
technical. I watched, I'm on
the regional circuit.
He fought in my hometown a few times.
I would go to their
special guests and watch
and I saw him, his financial and I
told Jean like, this kid can be good.
He trained up on the walkie but not Rufus
support. Right. Shaffer's at the time.
Yeah,
and I saw him.
I used to go down and train with her
now watching him a hidden pads and doing
something. He's funky. He
could me the want to go pro.
He can be a champion and they should
have his first fight went the way it did.
And then Kelly, I remember seeing
him in a hotel like Montel.
Let me highlights your fast like you know,
I know you got an sr,
you fight bro Quadro and do what
you do. You're, you're fucking good.
Like hit this dude as much as you can.
When he fired the shot,
get as a mission and you can't
fish with ground and pound.
You could finish this dude
like I got you bro. Thank you.
You are not doing it in the back. I was
like, man, I was surprised. Like I'm not,
I knew that. I seen what he's done in the
gym. I know what he can do. He's special.
He really is.
He's,
he's got real potential but he
doesn't freak me out as much as his,
as Brandon Davis turns away, looks healthy
at his way. Yeah. Brandon, David's like,
I couldn't believe that he ever weighed
one 35 when I'm looking at him like,
do you so big for that weight? And he was
45 before that and apparently they pie.
Do you have seed performance institute?
They're the ones who talked him
into going to 35 they'll look,
you could make the cut.
He was more than one 60 when he weighed
in when he was in the octagon and that
means, yeah, I heard him
say I'm about one six now.
Then the pis that he can make it.
That's good because when I went there,
because at one point coming
off the Osp or Jimmy,
I can't remember mark and then was like,
oh he always thinking about 85
that's how close your mouth. 300 pounds.
Like, well maybe like I tried to test cut,
didn't go well but not a is here.
So I emailed them and went out there
and we did a test and Clinton both said,
well Clinton,
both of them just get stronger cleaner.
Like I don't tell you right now. Crossing
and numbers compare to other numbers.
You walk around smaller, but when you put
your on a system, your numbers is like,
you're like gleaner the most of these
guys. I mean you can make 80 bucks,
you're probably like die. Like it
wouldn't be healthy at all. You,
it wouldn't be worth it. Well, so
many guys like Dustin poor, Yay.
So many guys going up in weight class,
but in the best thing that's
ever happened to them. So, um,
Jorge Mas fuddled so many guys that
go up to 70, they just look better.
Robert Whitaker Whitaker is
perfect. Champ champ. Yeah, I mean,
I think that it's a,
it's a bad environment when there's 20
pound weight gaps between like 85 and two
oh five or even 15 between 55 and 70.
These are giant wake gaps.
You've got the name from two
oh five to 85 that's 20 pounds.
You can make it like you did you see
me when I'm on a scale of 12 five now?
It ain't like I'm still flat. Like my
dad's was popping like my cheekbones.
I'm looking at a 20 zero pounds. Oh,
you'd be a dead man. Dead Man. I mean,
you'd have to literally like
do something to your body.
Like you'd have to run around
the streets is bring people.
It's finding like 20 miles a day.
Brandon Davis before that fight.
That's car person cause
he was a big 85 or yeah,
he fought two oh five I'm contingent,
but he wasn't like solid at 25 two or
five you can see he's still had more body
fat so it can get all, I remember
when I was a pianist, so I'm like,
you're going to become like a marathon
runner. Just can't, what do you mean?
And they gave him his meal plan.
It's like very small meals,
which you got around like five to
three to six miles a day. And then bike
after that another 10 15 at night.
So that's what we was doing.
Like Sunday hit me up like you're ready,
go to the park.
I would go bike 15 miles and I leave.
He go run the thing in the five
mile lubricant. They briars fucker.
He's our hatch if I want to make weight.
But now he's got it down pat.
So he doesn't have do to anymore.
We had to get his body to where he's
supposed to be walking around like two oh
five to 10 Max lean. So when you came
to camp, a good two three mile run,
get them down to a one night.
It's just like eat right and train and
then suck the last few pounds. Yes,
certain people like that,
but like when you see me I got to see
like next to glow rest my really pay
attention to it.
When I came in at two 36 on two weeks
notice we look about the same and we got
on a scale or when we did the face,
I know we turned side with it.
You kind of see like he's thinner,
but I got home,
my torso and everything is thick because
that was 300 pounds at one point.
I don't lose that for everything about
heavyweight in the UFC mark and said it
before.
Even say like Bro,
the way 85 two oh five and heavyweight
85 it's like two oh five hours.
That's a little smaller faster,
but they don't hit as far as hard as
they do in two oh five and heavyweight.
They hit hard,
but they're a lot slower and faster
than two oh five so you can go up and I
think you'll still do great.
And if you go down,
I think if you rehydrate it right back up,
you just go through everybody.
But I like to have five.
Like I said,
I haven't been dominated until somebody
showed me. I don't need to be here.
I'm not going anywhere.
Well,
especially when you're walking around
at two 35 that's really the weight class
for it. Yeah. Like I said, feel
great. Oh, I'm healthy weight. Yeah.
My fuck around at the heavyweight division
is so strange too because it's got a
weight limit, like two 65 always weirded
me out. Like why is there a weight limit?
Like there should probably be a two 25
and then there should be an unlimited,
you fucking get,
you know,
like a bunch of butterballs is rolling
around and tells him be born or giant
dudes like in Ghana that don't
even have to cut weight. You know?
You know like Curtis blaze. I know he
was a big one where he came in. Yeah.
I recruited him in college and I seen
him in high school. He was big. Then, uh,
who's another one? Um, won something.
He just came in from the contender light
skinned dude with the Afro. Real crazy.
He fought in Milwaukee,
the Milwaukee car heavyweight.
He fought my buddy and the contender,
they went out there three weeks before
and he was like two 90, something,
three or four.
My teammate was like two 50 already.
Not something my brothers ain't
gonna be no regional fight.
You need to come ready. This
dude is huge. When he hit you,
he's hitting you and if he gets you
to the ground, he's donkey Kong.
He has seen film on him in Kurdish blades.
Hit me up about him when he first started
fighting pro and it has seen film,
not sound like I seen film,
but looking at how big this kit is,
it's not going to be a fight you used to.
And sure enough,
I think my God took it like
he was like, oh, he's big,
but he's not going to be as fast
as me. Shit. He rehydrating up,
but he would athletic. It's, Oh
that was not a fight to watch.
But lessons learned.
Yeah. Now if you could,
if you were running shit of Corie
Anderson's president of the UFC,
what would you change? The rankings.
The rankings go back to where it was.
If you beat this guy, you move
up. Why did they do it now?
They do it based on like having no journal
runs it. Yeah, something like that.
Something like that. A bunch of Jews
vote for it. That's what they say. Yeah.
And in my mind I feel like,
I think somebody in the UFC still
has something to do with it,
but they swear up and down and every
time I say something I'll be like,
it's not them bro.
Somebody else.
But I don't know cause even mc after
the glow or fight, he told me like, Bro,
hello fight. Thank you for stepping in.
And you'd definitely be in the top five.
And I said in the interview
like I should be top five,
I got to feel it and I won't be.
And everybody an interview
like that sounds crazy. You
just be the number three,
your death would be top five. Wednesday
came out, number six. If it was really,
how does that make sense then
not be a leader. It's like,
oh there's no question you'll be top files
I think starts going great for
you and growing the right way.
Do you think you'd be like, well what
the fuck am I fighting against now?
No, that's why I made a tweet
that somebody posted before.
Like I'm just saying how Cory steady
dropping down the rankings when you got
guys like dominant wrist,
he beat Volcom who was four and everybody
saying he lost that fight but he's
Volcom was six actually
or something like that.
He lost that fight but he's jumped up
to four like how has he he off decision
like oh it's cause you
lose or win on decision.
They don't move rankings up for decision.
Then he went off decision.
He went up to number four and somebody
said how did that even possible?
I said it's to the point now I can't
worry about fighting hoopers and charges
the rankings and my opponent.
Cause if I worry about both of them,
I'm not focused on something.
So I'm just worried about the opponent
and I'm going to keep beating whoever
they put in front of me.
And eventually they keep trying to put
these guys up to fight John like off
knock outs. Like I said, Andrew
Smith, he knocked out Rashad, uh,
shogun and then choked out Vulcan.
He went up there to USC, John,
it didn't have nothing to ground.
All that extra stuff.
It's good when you're knocking guys out.
And I think somebody,
same thing with Santo, he known for
knocking guys out, but his losses,
I'm an 85 other than branch.
He also Eric Spicy on the ground.
John's good on the garage.
I was going to take them down.
Soon as you come running to me,
you hit him one shot,
I'm going to take you down and
he ain't gonna have no answer.
You know what I mean?
If you don't have everything tested by
the time when it's time to go to the
championship fight, if you ain't
do nothing, striking is over.
Tiago to me seems like,
I mean he's a very dangerous guy,
but almost like so aggressive that
he's almost like a kamikaze guy.
Like he's do or die
like kill or be killed.
He comes in just swinging and
throwing hammers and if he connects,
it's dangerous. If you can ask is bad
for everybody, but he might not connect.
You know? I mean it's, it's, that's
kind of how he is. He's, he's a,
he's a a wild card.
That's the best way to put it.
Like he could connect on John if John
fucks around and I don't think you will.
I think, I mean he hasn't ever before
except for the Gustafson fight.
I don't think he was prepared
as much as he should have.
And we saw that in the second
fight where he just dominated him.
But I think that if he makes a mistake,
Tiago could shut the lights out
on anybody. That guy has swings,
he throws like it's less sledgehammer.
Even rose is not trying to
make it to the final round.
Like he's not pacing themselves, does none
of that. That dude, he comes out hard.
But it's like
I think about him as my fight. We are a
little bit Chiefy going into that fight.
We, I knew 100% I live, he's going to try
rest of me, but if it can't take me now,
everything is going to be haymakers cause
he seen me get touched in the Chan and
go down a robble. So as long as I
keep moving, if I make him miss,
he's going to get tired and he's going
to stop throwing those big haymakers.
And sometimes when he's swinging,
he missed,
he almost falls over and it gives you
like the counter or to take down this
thing and our division,
there's so many people,
not more like rock 'em sock 'em robots I
think cause they got their hands up and
they blocking and it's like, oh he's not
hitting me. But with four ounce gloves,
I guess I'll put it like I was case half
a Ryan Bader and John's Anthony Johnson
Bader had his hands up.
Borama was hit his hand so hard.
Also you see his hands
just drop and he was out.
It doesn't matter if you let them hit
you is a chance to still getting wobbled.
And I think with John,
John's good at Aveda and punches most
guys in our block and counter back or try
to take a punch and hit you back.
Like take a punch to give a punch.
John's not that car. He's
going to move, move, move.
You swing he so long he can put his hands
out and keep your distance and hit you
with those quick fast long kicks and
stuff. And I just, like you said,
I don't see John Messing around.
He knows his dangerous. He's smart.
I will say John's not only the best
fighter if he's in mentally as a mixed
martial artist, he sees what's going
on really well. He knows how to debt.
He can go out there and try tricky stuff
at times when he know I can try some
stuff right here and get away with it
cause I'm long like with shogun fight.
And he went out there and
showed out jumping knees,
jumping to kicks because Shogun
was so short. He knew. He said,
I'm a different breed. I'm longer on fast
and trickier, but I think it would come.
A guy like Gus,
he didn't do all that stuff,
but he knew he had to stay long in the
vape punches and get the take down and
hit them where you can. Yeah. And the
Gus fight, he showed his metal, right.
It showed that he could take it and then
winning the championship rounds even in
the fight that it wasn't even
really properly prepared for.
He showed that in the Vito Belfort
fight too when he got caught.
But that arm bar, he overcomes
adversity. He's not just the hammer.
He knows how to be the nail. He knows
how to do it. Uh, well listen Corey,
you're a bad mother fucker. I appreciate
you coming here. It's just fun. It's fun.
You want to talk on more? We did
three hours, man, but we talk all MMA.
Let's get 30 minutes. 30 minutes.
Let's do it. I was like, Huh,
okay, let's talk. It's
fine if I'm a hunter.
But who you told me you're going on your
first elk hunting trip this year. Yep.
Getting out to Montana. We're part.
Is it around? I can't remember.
He gave me the codes to put into the,
the DNR site.
Are you using a different sectors? You
use it. A light set up out there for it,
but that's for target right here.
I got 60 pounds,
just like 62 or 63 and how many greens
arrows you still have like to 60 yeah,
that's a really light Arrow I'll use when
I go out there for Elka and I use you
to 300 so I got the grizzly stick weighted
tips, whatever, 300 grains, that's it.
That's what usually what I shoot.
I shoot five 25 525 grains.
I should pull 84 pounds.
I like uh, the tip and everything
and I don't know what it is,
but the answer is 300 wait,
wouldn't have with everything
I have to get to scale.
I'll make my own arrows and the
basement and all that, but I just,
I don't have a scale to see how much
your way at the end are you trying to do
that for speed is why you have the light
grains. That's just what the guy, my guy,
aces and arrows,
the hat I'm wearing actually in Vegas.
I'm going to connect you to John Dudley.
I mean,
I know you've already talked to him,
but I want to get you guys together next
time you anywhere near here and he's in,
or if you're in Vegas and he's in Vegas,
I'm going to get you guys together
and have them coach you and help you.
Cause I already,
I already see that you're very accurate.
You know when we're playing techno haunt
you or your scoring in the vitals every
single time, you know, except for one,
one little window by one body shop.
But even that's a dead elk where he,
where he hit it.
But John can help you
tremendously. He, he'll,
he'll tighten up your shit and I'll
show it that. I see his videos.
I studied that stuff all the
time. But again, he's like
the Mark Henry of archery.
I see it.
Yeah.
And hundred yard shot through
the Kettlebell and I'll
tell a friend all the time,
like I was the most amazing thing I've
ever seen. That whole, this big yard.
He went through an error only book.
Yup.
It's like you don't see people
shooting like cam is good too,
but I'm not saying he couldn't do it,
but I don't camp could do it too.
They have a Canada post videos
shooting through kettlebells lessons,
like some crazy videos too.
But I mean it's just that level of
commitment where they're just constantly
training, constantly doing. And John
is also just such a fantastic coach,
you know,
he's so good at understanding our true
fundamentals and explaining it to you.
The positioning and it's very much like
martial arts and that we would make a
few little changes and it does the world
of difference. I'm willing to learn.
Yeah. Most of the time I'm learning
on the fly. Like on my dad,
we learned how to shoot together and
I was like 12 when it was buddies,
like all you ever did
archery took him to the rain.
She got me a browning and I was a
kid, you know, shooting it at three,
shooting with him. It's kind of like
what I learned was from what he learned.
But if you know my dad,
everything other than work,
everything is Kinda like ghetto
guys are calling the ghetto Cabo.
We had horses and everything
and it was just like, do I,
you see people do it on TV when I was
not the way my dad learned how to ranch
horses,
it grabbed voices and saddle him up and
everything was kind of ghetto be ghetto
cowboy, you know. So now when I go back
from the things I learned and I tell him,
cause like you say, you see
my answer, I'm all hunting,
thank fight and I'm hunting constantly.
He was like,
where did you learn is it's just watching
videos and I go hunting with somebody
else's instead of talking like I talk
about what I know but most honest and I
listened to guys talk and
I ask a question like yeah,
like I don't know what it is but
I make it seem like I do. But yes.
What are you thinking about that?
And they break it down.
I had no clue about that.
Learn how to feel.
Address my first deer in Texas
with these guys, Harold Sports,
a bunch of veterans would go out.
They asked me and Justin Gates you,
that's how I got close with
Gigi hunting with those guys.
Well with veterans with amputate your leg,
so mental problems,
whatever is this and say
store and we kill a deer.
Like they've been hunting they whole life.
They grew up as kids so feel addressing
and how to call and like you shooting
the rifle.
I'm like,
oh you go to this website and
if you got 110 granted a bullet,
it shows you here at 300 yards.
Aim on this cross here and didn't like,
and I learned different
stuff from those guys.
Veterans that do this stuff for a living.
They ain't had been to war and
how to shoot a gun then God,
these are like John does.
I see his videos and his uh,
not school and Knox and would not
watch stuff like that. Like you said,
you haven't had any coaching.
Like what I'd do is just practice over
and over and over and I'm at the range,
the owner Mike of a. And. M,
he'll come out and be like, oh,
kind of tried to turn your head a little
bit more. I didn't have a kisser button.
Put a kiss with button though,
that have forced you to turn your head
and you need to be strict with the law.
Straight down and think about pushing
his lifeline through stuff like that.
I just practice,
I guess I'm shooting.
I used to shoot at least
a hundred barrels a day.
I guess I'll pop that chuck bit down,
put the radio on your sat there and shoot.
I shot one time so long I couldn't move
my neck back the next morning and I woke
up.
I could not.
I was stuck like I didn't even train
because I was stuck in my head turned like
this cause my Kay got tight because I
was crunching up here and doing this like
I wasn't supposed to, but it all
tightened up. Yeah, I mean, you know,
so I'm learning the hard way. She was
like, I went Turkey hunting this year,
this last week. Archery Turkey.
Never Been Turkey hunting before.
I've only seen on youtube or hurt
somebody telling me at the trade show the
great American outdoors.
And it just sounds so interesting.
And I started youtube in
an ordered all this stuff.
I need decoys and I was teaching myself
watching videos. Knock the first day,
I slayed, call him boss
call. I don't know.
That's not right now I can do that now.
I'll put it on the slate and it
sounded like an actual Turkey call.
And like I'm good in a week.
I just study in Sra. Right?
So stuff like that.
So I just look forward,
fuck with those heck suits. The who
heck suit. You know what it is? Agcs,
it's a, especially with
birds, birds, you know,
birds can navigate using
magnetics. They, they use,
they use like the magnetic pole
to and electromagnetic fields.
It's been proven that birds can
register and they see electric sense
electromagnetic fields. And they
think that birds in particular and,
and sea creatures too,
like they use it with a scuba divers and,
and a spear fisherman
and people like that.
There's a suit that blocks
the electromagnetic signal
that your body gives off.
And uh, it's put supposedly particularly
effective with Turkeys who, you know,
are very,
they see very well and they see
things movement and they're very,
very skiddish and they see any weird shit.
They just get the fuck out of there.
But, um, this guy, Mike's linkerd, who's
one of the guys who created the heck suit,
he hunts turkeys with no blind.
He just sits out in the field with
this heck suit on that blocks the
electromagnet magnetic signal.
And then he puts cammo on over the heck
suit and has videos of him doing this.
Man, it's Kinda crazy. You
know, this is a check. Yeah,
this is him sitting there.
So he's sitting with his heck suit on
right in front of these turkeys. Now,
you know as well as I know that most of
the time if you are right in front of a
Turkey like that,
they would get the fuck out
of Dodge Dakota put over.
But he's not, he doesn't have that.
They don't got the coin is hey, yeah,
I mean he's got somebody behind the giant
body behind them and he's, he's moving.
But the idea is that it can't see the
electromagnetic signal that you're giving
off. There's a lot of videos on
it. It's super controversial,
but a Dudley swears by it.
John Dudley swears by,
and a lot of other folks do too. Um,
Shane Dorian. Yeah, I think it does.
I think it works for everything. I think
animals can sense something. I mean,
it's not everything, right? I mean,
you still can't be downwind or
upwind, you know, if, if you,
if your wind comes and catches them,
they're going to smell you and they're
going to get the fuck out of there.
But it's a, what is that
another? Just Jesus Christ.
That's a great picture. Like there's
a perfect example of how camera works,
right?
That picture.
It's true. But you gotta if you to like
that picture of me, you tried that,
you're going to see me.
Perfect angle. And the filters, I
mean it's the perfect type of leaves,
the perfect gang goal, the
perfect lighting, you know,
it's probably fucked with a
little, but you know, the,
the heck suit is a very
controversial thing,
but people smarter than me say it works.
It really works with sea
creatures for some reason with um,
a things in the water because you know,
animals,
they have that lateral line or fish
rather have that lateral line and they,
they sense electrical signals that are
coming off of creatures that are in the
water. And so scuba divers
swear by this fucking the suit.
It's interesting stuff. Yeah, heard
it. Never heard. I'm like, wait,
I'll get them to send you some.
Yeah, for sure. Well, like I said,
I listened to Dudley when it comes to
every, I'm, you know, I'm like you,
when it comes to martial arts,
if someone's teaching me something,
I just listen. I don't,
I don't second gas.
And when a guy is wise is him says
that it works. I'm curious about it
and at least try it before I
knock. We don't work for me. Not,
maybe it's just I'm doing something wrong
and they come and show me and it still
don't work. It's Kinda like a,
I don't believe it. If it works,
I'm going to have a particular, uh,
Cammo company. CIC is the best. Yeah.
I love it there. The best. I mean, I got,
they gave me a little pro deal 50% off,
so I worked out. Yeah, I love it. It's
still expensive, but it's worth it. Yeah.
They,
they just have so much engineering and
their shit and guys like John Barklow,
the guy who was the designer that does
all the protesting and cold weather and
you ever see the cold water immersion
test they've done with their shit.
He's got a rewarming drill that he put
online explaining to people what you do
if you're in cold conditions
and you fall into the water,
like how to rewarm yourselves
got ahold video where he did it,
they jumped into this icy
river and then yet, nope.
And then climbed out. And you know, the,
the suits are designed in a lot of the
clothing is designed to allow you to
survive and that sort of a situation.
But you know,
you have to know how to do
it and how to go about it.
So he hears there's John and uh, this
guy that he's with and they just dumped,
there's John on the right and they'd dump
themselves in this freezing water and
then get out. And then they
put on sleeping bags and
gotten into the tent. And
I'm tell you right now that's been WPS to,
ah,
you're not going to see no black
man. Don't beat yourself. No.
All waters is the proof
point.
Um, well he's educating people. That was
actually when he was in the military.
That's what he did. He taught
cold weather survival. He's,
he's so thorough too.
And you know,
and he's one of the reasons why sit cause
gears so well engineered and designed
because they've got a guy like him that's
a telling them how to design things.
And he's a hunter too. He hunted with me
the, uh, last year I hunted elk with him.
And, uh, in Utah,
I'm actually going to get the test out.
Like my buddy told me before, like,
I promise you thicker, you get the
warm and stuff, no matter how cold,
you're not going to get cold,
like the best shit.
So I'm going to a Saskatchewan
can't if a white tail in November,
he told me if he say it case, he's like,
it's not that bad. It's kind of car.
It wasn't not bad. He was like
sometimes like negative fucking back.
You come right.
Well I've got an extra body suit
for you so I'm going to get there,
super warm gear and try it out.
And he said, if it don't worry,
I'll let you use the body suit.
But yeah,
you might need the body suit
and Saskatchewan is fucking,
I will test and see if it really works. I
might see your boys video, check it out.
That Canada, Cole's a different cold, you
know those people are hardy folks. Yeah.
You went out there and uh,
June for the bear hunt and actually me
and my dad in the mornings it was cold.
Yeah.
And at that time,
day the sun come out and then we go to
the top of the mountain to the sea glass
and you know man fast, like instantly
hands froze. I'm in the truck in the heat.
He just out there chilling in his t shirt
like this is hey dude is he's doing it.
Yeah. Now will you, when you were up there
was that spot and stalk or yeah. Yeah.
So you catching them when they were coming
out of the dens and heat and we have
to go up to the top of the viewing point.
That's how my mouth and we look me,
him and my dad,
he had the spotting scope and we both
from Manaca cause I just look for a black
guy. You see some of you tell me and I
put the spine Scott scope on it and see if
it's a,
a style or a bear.
We can get half something like office
hours cut her cubs. We're not shooting us.
We only won't old males and it's crazy
cause it's a 30 minute drive to the top
of the mountain. So after we seal
it might look like it's right there.
It's like like an hour to get down there
and we've got a park and then we still
got walk 2030 minutes and hope he's
still in that area. You know what I mean?
And like I said, we came across elk, we
came across cougars, all kinds of stuff.
But you get an that bear
was gone and we hopped in,
I back to the truck back to time and we
did it all day to like it got dark and
take us till midnight,
whatever to get home cause it was so
far into the mountains and it was great
like I said, but it will walk in and I
had the wrong boots. I like work boots,
my cat and stuff with burning the first
day. But, and I'm with the head guy is,
I don't like driving. I was like walking
a lot. So we did a whole lot of walk.
He's like, I figured you'd be a
UFC fighter, I could test you.
I never a guys athletic
as you that's able to walk. Most people
are overweight or not that athletic.
So you want to go a little bit. It's
time to go to the trip. Like you,
I can test you out a lot of cardio men,
man.
I never been so scared in my life. This is
my mom said like Mr Overtime, 25, eight,
like you ain't did it mom.
It's different.
It's different walking up those hills
and those guys that get used to it,
those very specific muscles that you use
when you're constantly hiking up hills
that you said you did it black per home
before I did a few bow or rifle in uh,
north of Alberta with my friends
John and Jen, the rivets up there.
They got a great camp up there.
I just don't have the time to get
away for that many camps, you know?
And I prefer elk hunting.
Can you do a year?
I'm going to do for this year,
for this year or two elk. Um, uh,
one axis deer and one mule deer.
Now what about Saskatchewan and whitetail?
You seen those? Fuck, what'd you do it?
Yeah, I would do it. Yeah, we'll do it.
He'd do whatever.
I can't because I do have something
scheduled in November already. Well,
you tell me what in more than 100 a month,
I'll get divorced.
My kids will beat me up.
I'm on the verge of that already.
I'm on every morning I get up four o'clock
she just put the baby back to sleep.
I'm up making noise. I wish me
luck. I see you when I get back.
I know they don't like it, man.
It's funny, but I get it. But it's,
it's one of those things that
just takes a lot of time.
Like if you're going to go on a
hunting trip, it's seven days away.
You know you have seven days and you're,
you're going to be probably somewhere
where there's no cell phone signal.
But for me, man, it's very
valuable for my head. I, I've,
I recenter out there. I get it, man.
There's fucking animals chasing deer
and things are trying to survive and it
just puts everything
into perspective for me.
When I'm sneaking up on an elk and I'm
tip toeing through the grass and I'm just
trying to get inside of like 60 70 yards
just to get a good shot off and I'm
trying to make sure the wind is ride
and I'm not thinking about anything else
man, nothing and why draw back and
I sent her my pin and you know,
and I put,
I'm looking through the peep site and
everything's right and the housing's level
and I've got my anchor point and I'm
pulling up my back muscles and I'm just
concentrating on that spot.
Aim Small, Ms. Small it all.
The whole world goes away.
The world goes away and when that
Arrow finds that crease and sinks right
through the, and you see those
fledglings disappear and you're like, ah,
we fucking did.
Cause some people will never understand
like why would you be happy you killed
an animal because it's so hard to do. It's
not that you're happy, the animals die,
you happy you did it. It's a
relief. It's so hard to do.
It's like people don't understand like
to maintain calmness and stillness when
you're drawing on an animal.
It's not like a rifle.
I've shot things of the
rifle and it's not easy.
It's more hard than people think it is,
but it's way easier than using a bow.
It's not even close because you've got
to draw it back without being spotted.
Yeah. Then you've got a hose steady.
The rife was how you got sticks.
Stick put his shoulder.
Like I said, it ain't easy,
but you find the crosshair once
you get it set up on a pull,
I pulled down so they don't see me.
So right now I'm starting to shake.
I've been helping.
Like the one I helped,
three minutes and 41 seconds I
had a record and eye health is,
but he kept stopping
bags.
No putting on like wobbly and I posted
a video after that killed like people
wonder why I'm so proud of my kids.
Like do you know what?
It's like being 235 pounds,
six three in a tree,
not being spotted hold and you got to
control your breathing and one role moving
my hand if I go to is something he seemed
my hat, mood or silhouette, he's gone.
It's like really like I post a
video and it looked like a picture,
like just me holding it
looked like a picture.
God never moved like I don't think anyone
would understand how hard it is to be
as big as I am all up in
the tree with a climber.
I'm using the cloud so that's hard
too and get up and just sit still.
The wind blow and everything. You can't
sway you sent. Everything has to be right.
It's an art to it.
People never know. They'll never
know. No unless they do it.
It's one of those things and many people
that get mad at people that do it are
meat eaters,
which drives me crazy.
They think there's something wrong
with killing wild animals like that.
That's the best way to do it
because these animals, first of all,
they're going to, you're going
to get organic, real wild
meat. It's better for you.
Second of all,
like these animals lived a real life.
They're not like came butcher shop
after I got the bed, me and my dad got
and we posted a picture and a lady,
she's in the same stuff in
the company and I know she's,
I've seen her at a barbecue,
her and her husband like pound and
burgers and I posted the picture, shit,
I can't believe you.
I will no longer follow you.
How could you dare go in a
while and kill a bear to eat it?
Don't chew,
eat burgers out.
You went and got a on somebody took and
chained up and slaughter you rather that
then me going out and getting them in
most natural way ever. Not only that,
if you love animals, you got to kill
bears because they eat everything.
They eat 50% of all the
deer fawns and El Calves,
they get killed by bears.
50% of them.
Like I post a picture of killing and
coyote wants and everybody like, oh,
did you get to coyote? Didn't do anything
to you. But the thing they didn't see,
I posted a video a week later I killed
the coyote as he was chasing down a dope.
He was like trying to
get them and I saw it.
I swung good and right when he came out,
POW flipped and it was over.
I saved the deer's life. Boy y'all saw
was the picture of the county. What?
You can't eat them. Yeah, but
I saved the other wildlife.
It's just you never make everybody happy.
You can't make anybody happy that doesn't
understand hunting, that's for sure.
They, they have this perception of it from
movies and from a lot of those redneck
stupid TV shows where,
you know, they just don't,
they don't portray
hunting in a positive way.
And so people get this
negative impression about it.
But I think with people like you, elite
athletes that are getting into a boat,
Jackson is a big bow hunter. You know,
there's a lot of boners now that are,
you know that we're just athletes
and they realize like, wow,
this is thrilling and exciting and
then it's the best meat in the world.
So you have so many
pros and it's the most,
I think it's the most ethical way to
eat meat because you're going out and
getting it yourself.
You're not hiring some supermarket hitman.
You're doing it yourself.
All right. That's the thing. Well
my youtube has the main point.
Ain't no ho about hunting.
It's more like one a black
guy on community to show him.
It was more than just killing. Like I so
far the one I'm at now is a Turkey hunt.
This whole week I'm out there
but I didn't kill anything.
But it's more showing you that.
It's more like you see the deer walk up
to view the sun coming up to sign going.
Right.
You, she said all this in editing
it. I'm doing it all myself now.
Do you think you'll have a career in
that after you get done with fiberglass?
Like I told when I meet people at the
shows that work with and work with me like
I don't know, what do you want? Like
I don't want no money or anything.
I just want to try to help.
If you can let me use one of your gear.
One of the thing and I advertise it,
I put you a little link at the beginning
tack the Cam Bolt Cream lift people I
use just put a thing on there cause I
don't want money but cause I'm just a
fight. I'm not a hunter. I love the
sport. I love hunting and you share,
you help advertise whatever.
I'm just wanting to get as well
as well known as I am in fighting.
I want the same thing and
hunting and without a dude's
as you bring other people,
cause I see like when I go to the boat
shop people were asked all the time like
I'm in today.
I was in a hotel on my been like oh
you got to get some of that a guitar.
Like no it's a bow and arrow. You see a
guy say, boy there he looked at it. Yeah.
Huh? I love hunting. Especially when
you see me. Like I told my wife,
I'm going to first person on Joe Rogan
shooting techno thing with Jordan's a do
rag.
What would a ball,
they don't work that way.
Nobody wearing [inaudible] and Jordan.
You see that guy on the
streets with sounds,
but then you see me with a boat or a gun.
I wonder if you're the first
guy to ever shoot tech dot.
Wearing a do rag and a bow.
You mark and Jordan's.
Someone's done that
before I went to do rec.
You might get somebody to do at the
Joe rags. Jordan's about to do. Right?
It's true. I got them both. You've
got the Combo, you know what I mean?
So that's the, I want people to see
what the show, not about hunting, just,
you don't have to be the
typical what people see.
You see country guys,
cowboy has cowboy boots,
kick shit kickers and the trucks and
that's the guy you expect to be a hunter,
right?
You got to walk around and came up.
But I want somebody to see because people
find out how like you, Huh? I love it.
That's it. I don't know. People
see a top level UFC fight or doing
it and they're like, whoa. Really?
Like this is life. Yeah, that's, I
love that. You love it man. It's, it's,
it means a lot to me, man. I,
I think that positive role models like
you or what the sport needs to change
people's boom. I don't want to say sport
cause I don't think hunting is a sport,
let's call it a disclosure. A culture
to change people's perceptions of it.
The positive people like you that are
elite athletes and just for people to get
a chance to see like, hey, this is the,
I mean I'm not encouraging
everyone to do it,
but I think there's a lot of
people that would love that.
I've never tried it because they may be,
don't have an an of what it actually
is. So if they see you or they see the
videos of you doing like Chad Mendez,
we'll deep, he's deepened. But that's
all he does. I love it. He loves it.
That's all he wants to do.
I mean he,
he basically is fighting to pay for
his hunting career, you know. Oh,
it, this is just scouting and stuff. Yeah.
But like right now I've got
this in Jersey. Yeah. This
is like behind my house.
You got Mavens, Huh? It's all a lie.
I, I see everybody think everything.
I post this stuff.
I got hooked,
know a lot of stuff I got I purchased
because I'll have maybe even hook you up
Brandon Weaver way yet. I actually
met him, I met him at the great,
that's not Baltimore. Great. Like I try
to understand like I'm a purchase this.
Oh that's good man. Good for
you. They make great shit.
I mean there's a lot of great
companies out there. The Guy Filming,
he was a teammate of mine. I hunts but
wanting to guy. I talked to Frankie Edgar.
He said he wouldn't do it. Somebody gave
him a bow. It's like, give me a ball.
I set it up. I show you how to get, I got
all my guys tell him I'll send the link.
Um,
do you hunter safety car and I take your
eye off film it and I'll show you how
to do it real. Like my buddies in Jersey,
he's a Jersey Shore Guido type guy,
but like I taught him how to
shoot it both 15 weeks ago.
Couldn't be kept mixing up the difference
between uh, is this your shop? Yeah,
this is a little pro shop in
the basement. Oh Wow. Nice.
So you set up your own
bows and everything.
You level your third access to all this
stuff. No kidding. That's great man.
I love it.
So the thing is just getting people,
I won't average Joes you get together with
Jim Miller, he's out there too, right?
He's up in a summit. I haven't
hunted with him, but we talked,
he's another one full balls deep.
I'm working with his guys at a and w
labs right now for like attracting and
whatnot. Then in Bocc creek are
the two I use NW labs and w last
and attract oh popcorn or whatever.
So like getting them on camera.
So like I use this stuff like
the killer queue. Like I said,
it's not just getting people in it,
but like getting these local shops.
Like he told him like we don't sell in
the stores. We tried to get a few here,
a few there, but like we don't have to
the network to get our name out there.
So those people like that, right.
Supporting those. I support me.
You helped me support me fighting
and how post your stuff, you know,
cause I got more followers than you.
So maybe somebody will click the
link for sure there and that.
Give it a try for sure. That's awesome
man. Do you have a perfect attitude?
I would. I would think, you know,
there's a lot of careers right
now in the hunting world.
Like a lot of guys make videos,
they post videos and they basically
make a great living just making hunting
videos. I mean, you can, you
can do that now, honey podcast.
Now you know Steve Rinella,
who's the guy who got me into
hunting in 2012 for that show?
You've seen him show me. Um, they,
they make tremendous money now touring.
They do these podcasts,
these bow hunting podcasts and then
they do them live. They don't live.
It's sold out theaters.
I mean it's crazy.
I mean I tried to get them involved in
podcasting years ago because he would be
on mine and he was so good at it.
I'm like, you're such a great talker.
You'd be perfect for this. And now
it's just one of the biggest things,
but it's one more way where guys can
make a living and also spread a really
positive message and be a great
ambassador for, for hunting,
for the hunting community. I guess
that's how posted on Frankie he did. Um,
the butcher box is that the new thing?
Not telling him like I've been trying
to tell him, go out to woods and Mac,
we can get you some meat. I got
hammered Ricardo meet if they want it.
I'm a freezer and somebody says
something about my comment. I was like,
I can give a man a fish and he had food
for days with, I teach a man to fish.
You have food for life. Like, yeah, he
can get this box right, like it'd be cool.
He was like, oh no, everybody got hunting
like you, but I can teach them. Yeah.
Anybody. That's what you can hit
me up anytime you willing to hunt.
If you can make it to me,
I will take you out.
And New Jersey is infested
with deer everywhere. Like, Oh,
you're a murderer prompt, but when it
hits your car, you mad. I'm saving.
You would have probably some guy in my
friend campaigns neighborhood last year
died guy in front of them hit a deer.
The deer went up in the air and came
through his windshield. Killed him.
That was a freak store.
Yeah, but if I killed him,
I shot the deer before he got to the
rope. Right. That wouldn't happen.
You saving lives.
I'm saving lives and getting Lyme
disease and ticks and everything.
I know you get on. Not yet. Oh,
I say all the time you're like obsessed
with ticks now you should. Exactly.
I was like, I feel like it's ticking on
me or something and maybe I got ticks.
I put the soy zone. I use lethal now
putting on my skin, everything good,
but have you in the woods not feel
something and sure enough fucking tick on.
I get home,
I got socks over my pants,
gloves over my sleeves and everything
tucked in and I take everything off.
I'll look in the mirror straight up,
be one of them. My back like dead ass.
I was at the Philly fights and me and my
buddies from heroes sports or something
like real flex. I'm on my back, my
version. What are you talking about?
We ain't on the back and I reached in my
shirt and sure now put fucking tick on
my back. Like fucking are we affiliated
to fights? Wow. Fucking ticket on.
They're everywhere.
Everywhere. They're everywhere.
In some giant percentage
of them have Lyme disease.
They say New Jersey is a highest and
festive place or it ticks and line.
I mean, you see what happened with Jim
Miller, I mean up for years. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean fuck my friend's son up.
He got bell's Palsy.
Where's his face went numb on the
sun. Yeah, it's fucking bad, man.
I think frank was a friend, Garrick
and one of the guys, the Jim,
his wife had lines. It's got bit a while
ago and she was messed up for awhile.
Marcus Davis,
you know Marcus Davis wound up using
all of his money he earned in the UFC to
help his wife because his wife got
real bad Lyme disease where she was
hospitalized for a long time.
Man, people don't understand that.
That shit can devastate you.
That is a dirty disease.
Those little stinking fucking text,
man, they can really mess your life.
I'm surprised cam don't get as much as
he carried a deer. Every time I see that,
and I'll be thinking of how do you
carry the deer on your neck? If he did,
he'd never tell anybody he would have
Lyme disease and just run 150 miles and so
a lot of disease dry it out.
He's a psycho II.
There's discipline and then this would,
that guy has, and this guy too though,
ya'll Goggins. He's another
one man. He's another one.
It's like these guys that like they,
they exhibit this next level toughness
to makes you reexamine what you're doing.
Like you think you're tough.
And then he found out what Goggins
what we say he'd ran like 28,
100 fucking mile runs in a row.
Something insane like that.
Why northern ones? A lot. Why?
Because when you run over two miles,
I look like why I get a text message
from Goggins say stay hard motherfucker.
This is, I'm checking in on you right
now. You hear him yelling at a tech.
Have you seen the um, document,
uh, Netflix losers? No,
I haven't looked it up. It's one on,
uh, the guy called lost in the desert.
It's the guy who runs, it's a desert
ruin. They do Karen what country?
But you go out there and he was just so
men, so obsessed with winning, I guess.
Thousands thousand people
running through this desert base.
Of course they had to follow when the
wind get bad, they got checkins away,
whatnot they supposed to follow.
And this guy, he was so obsessed,
he wasn't checking it.
He was like trying to take shortcuts and
like if I go to this way, I'll find it.
He had to go off the course and when
to clear it up. He was way off course,
but he was so obsessed.
I still got to finish.
He was out there for like five or
something. Five or six days. Yeah,
and that's talking about
how they announced to his
family. He told his family,
your husband's dead. We
can't find you. Find them.
They had helicopters
going all over the place.
He went to a point where he's
like drinking his own pissed.
He found this cave was full of bags
and start ripping the heads off,
mixing them up, drink it to survive,
drinking the bat, choose strategies,
mixing it up. And he like, at one point
I heard the helicopter coming over.
He took all his clothes,
all his gear,
dug a hole and set it on fire hoping
they would see him at the fire one up.
The wind blew it out so he didn't get
sick. So he out there with no gear,
no nothing in the middle of nowhere.
He's a vile. He ended up getting back.
His mind was like, I have to
finish. He's a, everybody left.
He said when he got there to check.
Point was gone,
but his friend had flew back to find them
and sure enough he from his friend was
there,
found them in a desert.
It's called the document's
called losers here.
Losers in the episode is lost in the desk.
The whole show is good.
All the little things on it was good,
but that lost in the desert one.
He ended up divorcing.
His wife was his wife left him
because after that he still went back.
He came home and she was like, you're not
going back to like I'm doing it again.
I have to finish and now he still does it.
He divorced his wife.
His wife left him when his wife left
him because you've got a family.
When she left, when he left, she was
mad like, what about your family?
People die on this. What? It happened. He
was like, don't worry. This isn't this.
I love this. I have to do it. When
he came back and his wife was like,
we're not doing it again. He was like,
yes, I am like, you just don't like,
he was pretty much dead.
They put him in the hospital.
They found them and everything. He ended
up doing it again. Mauro prosperity.
Wow.
The survival story of moral Prospera
disoriented after a sands torn so hard
desert does.
Italian ultra marathon runner
walked nearly 200 miles to safety.
Uh, but he's Italian. He's probably
going to get divorced to anyone.
Hey, what? I know those fucking guys
are animals. You know, you see it.
You're going to be like,
I have to.
I want you to direct DME after you watched
and I will see it when he ate the bad
Jews. I like that. I was just
killing myself there. I'm not,
was really biting their heads off.
Just any Cape Dark. No, but he could.
He was feeling for him.
He can see the eyes he grabbed.
That's how you would survive a k.
What kind of diarrhea? That guy have
even killed it. He tried to kill this
stuff actually, but he was so dehydrated.
He cut his wrist because they
had the last surfing here.
He cut his wrists with and went
to bed hoping he's going to wait,
like not wake up and you woke up. He,
he's like, what in the world? He said,
that was my sign that I
wasn't supposed to die.
He said when he got [inaudible] they said
you were to die dehydrated, complete.
So he didn't have anything. He
couldn't believe he's healed. He's,
he said that was it and he was pointing.
I felt myself faint.
I just kept telling myself,
I'm here. I have to make it.
I have to make it and have to make it.
And he said he find like he see like
some girl walking out in the desert.
He's like walking away. She was
going then the army, whatever arm,
wherever they was at,
the army had to come get them and they
got guns and she thinks he's going to die.
They ended up taking him to the house.
When he woke up,
he had ivs and everything and they
recovered. It took him back to his family.
It's a crazy story.
Like all of them was good,
but that was my brother calling me like,
wash that Bro.
You got a mentality like that.
You are fucking man washed
that two days any,
he stumbled into an abandoned Muslim
shrine where he noticed some bats huddled
together. Prosperity,
grabbed a handful of them,
cut off their heads with a knife and
then sucked out their insides to drink
their blood and quenches thirst.
Eventually he did his Vampire Act on 20
bats when another three days pass with
no signs of rescue.
He slit his wrists and waited to die,
but his blood and thickened due to
dehydration so it wouldn't drain out.
Fuck man.
Like that.
Some goggles and candidate to get together
and do a podcast and talking about
that like that was,
they wouldn't
cut the wrist.
They
killed themselves. They would have
just kept going. I think that those,
those kinds of people is ultra
marathon people. It's a different,
there's different breed of human, you
know, they, it's like everything has,
there's levels right to everything.
There's levels you, you've,
you've experienced it in your
own life where you tough it up,
you became a stronger person, a harder
person. And then there's levels past that.
And then there's levels past that.
And especially for people
that have one solitary thing,
they do like ultra marathons, they're
all skinny dudes who can just keep going,
just keep going. It's just, it's,
it's the, the pulling it off the,
crossing the line and knowing that
you did something that seemed almost
impossible. So, so titanic, Lee,
epically difficult to do that. So few
people can ever do it. When they do,
they're talking about running a 500 mile
race now because they did the Moab to
30 and they had the big foot 200 they'll,
all these people that are putting
on these races, they be like, okay,
we could do to 40 let's see if we could
do 500 so now talking about doing a 500
mile race,
it's next level.
It's hard for me to run a five K I
hearing what? You're a big fellow too.
I mean I could do it,
but I did in college and I've never been
like a nothing calculated like you had
to pay do again. It was like a charity
we have to do for college. Nope.
Never again. Have you ever thought
about doing something like that?
Like I'm going to go around and
around five K I ain't Finna pay.
It's like going Scott, I, well,
I'm going to jump out of perfectly good
plane to go into ground pay to run a
five k like what are they?
Is it organizing it again?
Most of them I go to
foundations and stuff like that,
but even then like you heard about
the foundation that take money.
I don't trust do you do here, but I
was like, I'm not paying no punting.
Some books to go run 13.1
miles. Right. Cool people.
It's more the fact that I can say I
did it. I can say I did it on my own.
I run 13.1 miles, my phone,
13 miles. We're good.
Tracked my mind, track my ruin. Boom.
Tell me how far I go and hit
13 I'm done calling a taxi.
But you like when you're a big
guy like you, you probably,
it's probably not good to run a lot of
miles. Right. And a lot of pounding,
especially on flat foot shit.
I'm so flat.
Like my ankle was like touching the
inside of the ankle says I'm so flat foot
and then five plus zero zero arch at all.
It's like I get a new pair of shoes every
can't we have to campus over cause by
all the movement at random dude,
I use the same shoes.
Athletic shoes for hitting Mitts
and shadow boxing and running.
So we're all at a flat foot
is pushing down, pushing down.
My time is time to fight.
It's going like,
I feel that my feet are hurting and my
cats hurt. I know it's time for new shoes.
Minimalist shoes like those toe
shoes or a minimalist shoes.
They make them in my size. What size? 14
I bet they do. I guarantee you they do.
They make them in 11 I'm 11 now.
Yeah. That's the big difference.
They make everything in 11 and
13 I had to sweating 14 yes,
roommates and I was big.
I was six foot tall or
freshman year in high school.
At 13 years old I was six foot. Wow. Yeah.
I like that. Was a heavyweight
from freshman year high school.
A senior in college.
That's two 15 to 85 what motive
you to go down to motivated?
You go down to two oh five well I went,
I did a catch weight fight at like two
20 the fight before I went to ultimate
fighter. When I went there I had to
go to a five of course as you made it,
you wanted to build here.
You might as well try it,
go to a five like you can do it. I know
you can do it. Once I got, it's like,
all right, I can do this. There was
like 85 like I can't, I'm not doing it.
I could do it but I'm not doing it.
I remember what it took to get here.
It Ain't worth, it's not worth
it. It's you're, you're too big.
If you look at you like I think a
lot of guys have fucked a career.
So by doing that,
dropping too much weight,
you guys think you really get rocked off
a punch, then you're very dehydrated.
That one little touch,
like I said,
I think that was a part of the reason
why I got knocked out against Jimmy.
So I was so light.
I weighed in at two oh five and next day
I weighed in at two 12 going into the
green. He was two 29 checking in
and he weighed in at two 27 before,
during and he said like you choose small
and I feel like my mind, like I said,
I used to keep myself so low.
Like when I wake up and when I get
up so fast so have to sit back down.
Like I could tell I was getting
lightheaded so easy you I what?
I was doing too much.
I didn't get lightheaded and I
have to sit there for awhile.
Let's drink some water and stand up slow.
That's the feeling you get when
you couldn't. That's so crazy.
But I was feeling that all the time.
Do something too fast and training and
it had to sit down in a matter about,
yeah, give me a second and I'll
stand up. I got terrible. Yeah.
But in my mind is like, if I stay here,
I'm always ready for a fight. Okay.
It wasn't good
at all. No, no. You cutting back on your
performance in a big way, but listen,
man, now we did a half hour
more, so that's good. Let's
get the fuck out of here.
And uh, it's good to go on a hunt,
man. Let's you and me doing it. Okay.
We'll figure something out. This,
I'm, I'm all booked up for this fall,
but maybe next year we'll start planning.
Right. I'd like to take you out to Utah.
I was, especially after this year's elk
hunt and I'm, you're going to love it.
All right. Do it Corey Anderson.
Thanks sir. Bye everybody.
That was great.
Okay.